[MUSIC]
>> GOOD MORNING EVERYONE!
AND WELCOME TO
RADCLIFFE DAY 2015!
AND WE DO HAVE A
SPECTACULAR DAY.
SO I'M SO HAPPY
THAT YOU'RE HERE.
I'M LIZ COHEN.
I'M DEAN OF THE RADCLIFFE
INSTITUTE FOR ADVANCED STUDY.
[APPLAUSE]
I KNOW THAT WAS
FOR THE INSTITUTE.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE RADCLIFFE
PAST, PRESENT, AND FUTURE.
AND WE HONOR JUSTICE
RUTH BADER GINSBURG
WHO WILL RECEIVE THE RADCLIFFE
MEDAL THIS AFTERNOON.
[APPLAUSE]
IT IS A TRADITION TO BEGIN
RADCLIFFE DAY WITH A PANEL
DISCUSSION THAT
CONNECTS DIRECTLY
WITH THE LIFE'S
WORK OF OUR HONOREE.
THE PANEL IS NOT
DEDICATED PURELY
TO OUR MEDALIST'S
SUCCESS, THOUGH THAT
WOULD BE RICHLY
DESERVED AND EASY TO DO.
INSTEAD, WE EXPLORE
THE COMPLEXITIES
AND THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY ANYONE WORKING
TO CHANGE THE WORLD.
THE RADCLIFFE MEDAL
CELEBRATES THOSE
WHO DO THE HARD WORK AND
FIGHT THE GOOD FIGHT.
THEY WIN MANY, BUT NOT ALL.
LAST YEAR OUR RADCLIFFE MEDALIST
WAS HARVARD PRESIDENT DREW
GILPIN FAUST WHO IS
HERE WITH US TODAY.
[APPLAUSE]
THE MORNING PANEL
THAT RADCLIFFE DAY
WAS TITLED FROM CIVIL
WAR TO CIVIL RIGHTS,
THE UNENDING BATTLE TO VOTE.
AND IT FOCUSED ON THE HISTORY
OF CIVIL RIGHTS AND ACCESS TO
VOTING, IN HONOR OF DREW'S
COMMITMENT TO SOCIAL JUSTICE.
OUR EXPERT PANELISTS
DISCUSSED MORE
THAN A CENTURY OF
CONTROVERSIAL VOTER ID LAWS,
REDISTRICTING PLANS,
AND COURT DECISIONS,
ALONGSIDE SUCCESSFUL EFFORTS
TO ENFRANCHISE MORE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THE YEAR BEFORE THAT WE HONORED
JANE ALEXANDER, ACTOR, ARTS
ADVOCATE, AND FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE NEA.
ON THAT PANEL TITLED FROM ARTIST
TO AUDIENCE, A POET, A PAINTER,
A COMPOSER, A CURATOR, AND
A THEATER DIRECTOR SPOKE.
THEY SHARED THE CHALLENGES
FACED BY BOTH EMERGING
AND ESTABLISHED
ARTIST TO PRODUCE
NEW AND IMAGINATIVE WORK AMIDST
ALL THE FUNDING OBSTACLES.
AND THEY REMINDED US OF THE
ENDURDING POWER OF CREATIVITY.
CHIEF JUSTICE MARGARET
MARSHALL, TODAYS MODERATOR,
WAS AWARDED THE RADCLIFFE
MEDAL THE PRIOR YEAR.
THAT PANEL EXPLORED
DYNAMIC BETWEEN
THE LAW AND SOCIAL CHANGE.
TITLED FROM FRONT
LINES TO HIGH COURTS.
ITS TOPICS RANGED FROM LABOR
REFORM TO EDUCATIONAL ACCESS,
TO MARRIAGE EQUALITY
AND REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS.
IN THE COURSE OF
DISCUSSING STIGMAS,
SETBACKS, AND SUCCESSES, THE
PANELISTS CONSIDERED THIS
QUOTATION FROM MARTIN
LUTHER KING, JR.
THE ARC OF THE MORAL
UNIVERSE IS LONG,
BUT IT BENDS TOWARD JUSTICE.
BUT HOW DO WE MEASURE THAT ARC?
ONE WAY IS BY UNDERSTANDING
THE POINTS THAT GIVE ITS SHAPE
AND DIRECTION.
FOR THIS MORNING'S
DISCUSSION WE ARE
LOOKING AT DECISIONS
AND DISSENTS
IN THE FIRST DECADE OF THE
ROBERTS COURT THAT MARK
THE PATH OF THAT ARC AS
IT MOVES THROUGH HISTORY.
JOHN G. ROBERTS WAS NOMINATED
TO THE POSITION OF CHIEF JUSTICE
BY THEN PRESIDENT
GEORGE W. BUSH IN 2005.
AT THE TIME OF HIS CONFIRMATION,
CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
SAID JUDGES ARE LIKE UMPIRES.
UMPIRES DON'T MAKE THE RULES.
THEY APPLY THEM.
HE WENT ON TO SAY
I WILL REMEMBER
IT IS MY JOB TO CALL BALLS AND
STRIKES, AND NOT TO PITCH OR
BAT.
IN THE TEN YEARS SINCE,
THE ROBERTS COURT
HAS MADE A LOT OF CALLS.
THEY HAVE CALLED SAFE AND THEN
CALLED OUT ON DOCTOR ASSISTED
SUICIDE, VOTING RIGHTS,
CAMPAIGN FINANCE REGULATIONS,
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
TO NAME ONLY A FEW.
THIS MORNING OUR PANELISTS WILL
HELP US DECIPHER THESE CALLS.
AND I CANNOT THINK OF A BETTER
UMPIRE THAN CHIEF JUSTICE
MARGARET HILLARY MARSHALL.
[APPLAUSE]
MARGIE HAS HELD MANY
IMPRESSIVE TITLES,
INCLUDING PARTNER AT CSAPLAR
AND BOK, PARTNER AT CHOATE, HALL
AND STEWART,
PRESIDENT OF THE
BOSTON BAR ASSOCIATION.
GENERAL COUNCIL OF
HARVARD UNIVERSITY.
AND OF COURSE CHIEF JUSTICE
OF THE SUPREME JUDICIAL COURT
OF MASSACHUSETTS.
WE LIKE TO THINK THAT
RADCLIFFE MEDALIST
IS ALSO ONE OF
HER PRIZED TITLES.
AND WE ARE HONORED THAT SHE
WILL BE GIVING HER PAPERS
TO OUR SCHLESINGER LIBRARY.
[APPLAUSE]
AS AN ASIDE, LET ME PROUDLY
MENTION THAT THE SCHLESINGER
LIBRARY HAS A NEW
FACULTY DIRECTOR.
AND SHE IS WITH US TODAY.
HISTORIAN AND
AUTHOR JANE KAMENSKY
WILL BE JOINING THE RADCLIFFE
INSTITUTE AND THE HISTORY
DEPARTMENT AT
HARVARD IN THE FALL.
[APPLAUSE]
THE SCHLESINGER
LIBRARY'S MARSHALL PAPERS
WILL BE A REMARKABLE
RESOURCE FOR ALL
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN CHIEF
JUSTICE MARSHALL'S VALUES AND
VIEWS.
DURING HER 14 YEAR
TENURE AS CHIEF JUSTICE,
SHE AUTHORED MORE
THAN 300 OPINIONS.
THE BEST KNOWN IS LIKELY
GOODRIDGE V. DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
WHICH IN 2003 MADE
MASSACHUSETTS THE FIRST STATE TO
LEGALIZE MARRIAGE FOR SAME SEX
COUPLES.
[APPLAUSE]
THIS IS A DECISION THAT
REVERBERATES MORE THAN A DECADE
LATER, AS YOU CAN SEE.
INCLUDING VERY RECENTLY IN THE
CHAMBERS OF THE ROBERTS COURT,
AS WELL AS GLOBALLY WITH
LAST WEEK'S VOTE IN IRELAND.
[APPLAUSE]
MARGIE RETIRED FROM HER POSITION
AS CHIEF JUSTICE IN 2011.
BUT HER WORK IS FAR FROM DONE.
SHE TEACHES AT HARVARD LAW
SCHOOL, SHE SERVES AS SENIOR
COUNSEL AT CHOATE, HALL,
AND STEWART, AND SHE
CONTINUES TO SHAPE
OUR APPRECIATION FOR
AND UNDERSTANDING
OF THE JUDICIARY.
SO IT IS WITH GREAT
PLEASURE AND GRATITUDE
THAT I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING THIS MORNING'S
MODERATOR MARGARET MARSHALL.
[APPLAUSE]
AND OF COURSE WELCOME OUR
GUEST OF HONOR, OUR HONOREE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
AND FOR THOSE OF
YOU AT THE BACK,
YOU MAY NOT HAVE UNDERSTOOD
THAT JUSTICE RUTH BADER GINSBURG
JUST ARRIVED AND I FRANKLY DON'T
THINK THAT WAS A SUFFICIENTLY
WARM WELCOME, SO COULD YOU
PLEASE WELCOME AGAIN JUSTICE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: THANK YOU.
JUSTICE GINSBURG, IT IS
WONDERFUL TO HAVE YOU HERE.
WE ARE GOING TO PROCEED THIS
MORNING BY TALKING ABOUT THE
PAST TEN YEARS OF YOUR
COURT, AND DISCUSS
SOME OF THE DECISIONS THAT
HAVE COME DOWN IN THAT TIME.
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
I THINK ALWAYS
IS DOES A CHIEF JUSTICE
MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW ABOUT THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT I DO KNOW WE DO TALK ABOUT
THE WARREN COURT AND THE BURGER
COURT, AND THE REHNQUIST COURT.
AND WE THOUGHT AFTER TEN YEARS
OF CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS,
WE COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE ROBERTS COURT.
THIS MORNING WE HAVE
FOUR EXTRAORDINARY
PEOPLE WHO REALLY
KNOW A LOT ABOUT
WHAT GOES ON IN THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT.
THREE OF THEM
BECAUSE THEY WORKED
FOR JUSTICES ON THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT.
THREE DIFFERENT JUSTICES.
AND ONE OF THEM,
BECAUSE FOR 30 YEARS
SHE FOLLOWED EVERY
MOVEMENT, EVERY SYLLABLE,
EVERY SENTENCE OF
THE ROBERTS COURT.
AND I HAVE TO SAY,
LINDA GREENHOUSE,
THAT YOU KNOW MORE INSIDE
STUFF THAN ANYBODY I KNOW.
BUT SHE WILL TELL YOU
THAT SHE NEVER GOT
ANY OF IT FROM THE LAW CLERKS.
AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY CORRECT.
WHAT WE DECIDED TO DO IS
HAVE A VERY SIMPLE FORMAT,
WE'VE HAD SOME WONDERFUL
DISCUSSIONS LEADING UP TO THIS.
EACH OF THE THREE, JOHN
MANNING, AND LINDA GREENHOUSE,
AND LAUREN SUDEALL
LUCAS ARE GOING
TO PRESENT THREE CASES,
AND THEN THE FOUR OF THEM
ARE GOING TO DISCUSS
DURING AND AFTER.
AND THEN PROFESSOR KLARMAN WHO
CLERKED FOR JUSICE GINSBURG
IS GOING TO MAKE A FEW REMARKS
BEFORE WE ADJOURN TO LUNCH.
SO, PROFESSOR MANNING.
>> JOHN MANNING: THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CHIEF JUSTICE MARSHALL.
I WANT TO THANK DEAN
COHEN AND THE RADCLIFFE
INSTITUTE FOR PUTTING ON THIS
WONDERFUL EVNET, AND TO THANK
CHIEF JUSTICE GINSBURG FOR
BEING HERE AND TO CONGRATULATE
HER ON THE LATEST IN A LONG
SERIES OF MANY WELL DESERVED
HONORS.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
SUPREME COURTS FAMOUS DECISION
IN NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS V.
SEBELIUS.
THE CASE GOT A LOT OF HEADLINES
FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS.
FIRST AT THE MOST BASIC LEVEL
IT UPHELD THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT, OR AS THE PRESS
LIKES TO CALL IT OBAMACARE.
THAT WAS A BIG DEAL
IN AND OF ITSELF.
THE COURT SAYS THAT CONGRESS HAS
THE CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO
ORDER YOU OR ME TO
BUY HEALTH INSURANCE,
OR PAY A FEE OR
FINE IF WE DON'T.
CONGRESS HAD NEVER QUITE DONE
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BEFORE,
SO THE DECISION
ITSELF WAS A BIG DEAL.
SECOND, THE COURT DIVIDED IN A
KIND OF GOOFY, INTERESTING, AND
REVEALING WAY.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW, ONE THAT MADE PEOPLE
KIND OF SCRATCH THEIR HEADS
AND SAY WHAT'S GOING ON.
CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS WAS AT
THE CENTER OF ALL OF THIS.
IN ONE PART OF HIS
OPINION THE COURT
SAID THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE COULD BE JUSTIFIED
UNDER CONGRESS' POWER TO TAX.
UNDER THE CONSTITUTIONAL
TAXING POWER
EVEN THOUGH CONGRESS HAD
NOT CALLED THE THING A TAX.
THERE CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
WAS JOINED BY THE COURT'S FOUR
DEMOCRATIC APPOINTEES.
IN ANOTHER PART OF THE CHIEF
JUSTICE'S OPINION HE WROTE THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE COULD
NOT JUSTIFIED AS AN EXERCISE
OF CONGRESS' POWER TO
QUOTE REGULATE COMMERCE
AMONG THE SEVERAL STATES.
IN OTHER WORDS OBAMACARE PASSED
MUSTER UNDER THE TAXING CLAUSE
BUT FLUNKED THE COMMERCE CLAUSE.
THOUGH NO OTHER JUSTICE
JOINED THE CHIEF'S OPINION
ON THE COMMERCE
CLAUSE, THE COURT'S
FOUR OTHER REPUBLICAN APPOINTEES
WROTE A JOINT DISSENT THAT
ESSENTIALLY SAID THE SAME
THING AS THE CHIEF JUSTICE DID.
THIS IS AN ODD TURN OF EVENTS.
USUALLY IF THE COURT FINDS THAT
CONGRESS HAS THE POWER TO DO
SOMETHING UNDER ONE CLAUSE
OF THE CONSTITUTION,
IT DOESN'T BOTHER TO OPINE ON
WHETHER IT HAS THE POWER TO DO
THE SAME THING UNDER ANOTHER
CLAUSE OF THE CONSTITUTION.
WE CALL THIS A DICTUM.
AND THE COURT ISN'T SUPPOSED
TO WRITE ON ABSTRACT QUESTIONS
THAT DON'T AFFECT THE
OUTCOME OF THE DECISION.
BUT TODAY I'M ACTUALLY GOING
TO TALK ABOUT THE DICTA IN THE
CHIEF JUSTICE'S OPINION
ABOUT THE COMMERCE CLAUSE,
BECAUSE I THINK THAT PART OF
THE CHIEF'S OPINION CRYSTALLIZES
THE ROBERTS COURT'S APPROACH TO
FEDERAL CASES MORE GENERALLY.
I THINK THIS COURT
LIKE ITS PREDECESSOR,
THE REHNQUIST COURT
FEELS VERY COMFORTABLE
SECOND GUESSING CONGRESS'
LEGISLATIVE JUDGMENTS ABOUT HOW
TO CARRY ITS POWERS INTO
EFFECT BASED ON THE COURT'S OWN
ABSTRACT ASSESSMENTS OF THE VERY
BROAD CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLE
OF FEDERALISM OR
RESERVED STATE POWERS.
NOW IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE UP
FRONT THAT THE CHIEF JUSTICE
AND THE JOINT DISSENT AT LEAST
PROPORTED TO REST ON THE
TEXT OF THE COMMERCE CLAUSE.
AS YOU MIGHT THINK.
THEY WANTED TO POINT TO SOME
PART OF THE CONSTITUTION THAT
WAS AN ISSUE.
THEY ARGUED BECAUSE THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE TOLD PEOPLE
SITTING AT HOME MINDING THEIR
OWN BUSINESS TO GO OUT AND BUY
SOMETHING, THAT THERE WAS
SIMPLY NO COMMERCE HERE
FOR CONGRESS TO REGULATE.
IN OTHER WORDS,
WHAT THEY SAID WAS
IN THE STATUTE THAT
CONGRESS CREATED RATHER
THAN REGULATED COMMERCE, AND
THAT THAT WAS NOT PERMISSIBLE.
LOOK, THIS IS AN
INGENIOUS ARGUMENT.
INGENIOUS.
BUT IT DOESN'T HOLD WATER.
[LAUGHTER]
AND HERE'S WHY.
THE OBAMACARE STATUTE IS ALL
ABOUT INTERSTATE COMMERCE.
EVEN IF I'M SITTING AT HOME
MINDING MY OWN BUSINESS NOT
BUYING ANYTHING
MUCH LESS INSURANCE,
THERE IS A MASSIVE INTERSTATE
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKET
OPERATING ALL AROUND ME.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE UNQUESTIONABLY
AND QUITE DIRECTLY REGULATES
THAT INTERSTATE MARKET.
AND HERE'S HOW.
A DIFFERENT AND UNCONTESTED
SECTION OF THE ACA SAYS THAT
YOU AND I HAVE THE RIGHT TO GO
OUT AND BUY INSURANCE, EVEN IF
WE HAVE PREEXISTING CONDITIONS.
SO IF I'M A HEALTHY
YOUNG PERSON,
WHY ON EARTH WOULD I BUY
INSURANCE UNTIL I NEEDED IT?
THAT IS TO SAY UNTIL
I ACTUALLY GOT SICK.
THIS INCENTIVE THREATENED TO
DRAIN THE HEALTHIEST PEOPLE
OUT OF THE RISK POO IN THE
INTERSTATE HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKET.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
REGULATES THE INTERSTATE
COMMERCE AND INTERSTATE HEALTH
INSURANCE MARKET BY PUSHING
THOSE POTENTIAL FREE RIDERS
BACK INTO THE RISK POOL, PLAIN
AND SIMPLE.
SO IF IT'S NOT THE TEXT
OF THE COMMERCE CLAUSE
THAT'S REALLY DOING THE
WORK HERE, WHAT IS IT?
CERTAINLY NO CLAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION TELLS CONGRESS
THAT IT CAN'T MANDATE
INDIVIDUAL BEHAVIOR.
NOR IS THERE ANY UNSTATED
CONSTITUTIONAL TRADITION OR
PRACTICE OR LINE OF PRECEDENT
THAT PROHIBITS CONGRESS FROM
ORDERING PEOPLE TO BUY THINGS
IF DOING SO WOULD HELP CONGRESS
REGULATE INTERSTATE COMMERCE.
SO WHAT EXPLAINS THE CHIEF
JUSTICE'S AND THE JOINT
DISSENT'S POSITION?
A COUPLE OF THINGS.
FIRST, AS I MENTIONED, CONGRESS
HAD NEVER DONE ANYTHING QUITE
LIKE THIS BEFORE.
FOR THE JUSTICES WHO WERE
SKEPTICAL OF THE COMMERCE POWER
JUSTIFICATION FOR THE STATUTE,
THE ABSENCE OF A PREEXISTING
PRACTICE OF, LIKE THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE,
WAS QUOTE THE MOST
TELLING INDICATION
OF A CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE OR
A CONSTITUTIONAL INFIRMITY.
SECOND, THE STATUTE
REFLECTED A LARGE EXPANSION
OF FEDERAL POWER.
AND THE CHIEF JUSTICE'S WORDS
QUOTE ALLOWING CONGRESS TO
JUSTIFY FEDERAL REGULATION
BY POINTING TO THE EFFECT OF
INACTION ON COMMERCE WOULD
BRING COUNTLESS DECISIONS AN
INDIVIDUAL COULD
POTENTIALLY MAKE WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF FEDERAL
REGULATION AND EMPOWER
CONGRESS TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS FOR HIM.
TO PUT IT COLLOQUIALLY,
IF CONGRESS CAN
MAKE US BUY INSURANCE, IT CAN
ALSO MAKE US EAT OUR SPINACH.
ACTUALLY THE COURT
SAID BROCCOLI.
BUT YOU GET THE IDEA.
THAT THE CHIEF JUSTICE WROTE IS
NOT THE COUNTRY THE FRAMERS' OF
OUR CONSTITUTION ENVISIONED.
AT ONE LEVEL THE CHIEF JUSTICE
IS QUITE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS NOT THE COUNTRY
THE FRAMERS ENVISIONED.
BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY THE
LEGALLY RELEVANT POINT.
EVEN FOR ORIGINALISTS.
THE FRAMERS OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T
ANTICIPATE A COUNTRY OF 320
MILLION PEOPLE, A GLOBAL
ECONOMY, UBER CARS,
APPLE WATCHES, OR EVEN AN
INTERSTATE HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKET.
WHAT THEY DID
ANTICIPATE WAS THIS.
THAT THEY COULDN'T
FORESEE THE FUTURE.
AND THEY EXPLICITLY
PROVIDED FOR THAT REALITY
IN THE DESIGN OF
THE CONSTITUTION.
AND HERE'S WHAT THEY DID.
THEY DID SO BY GIVING CONGRESS
PRIMARY AND BROAD AUTHORITY
TO ADAPT FEDERAL POWER
TO UNFORESEEABLE CHANGE.
AS THAT OTHER CHIEF
JUSTICE MARSHALL
SAID IN A FAMOUS OPINION CALLED
McCULLOCK VS. MARYLAND WHICH
UPHELD CONGRESS' POWER
TO CREATE A CENTRAL BANK,
THE FRAMERS KNEW
THEY COULD NOT DEVISE
A COMPLEX SET OF RULES FOR
A CONSTITUTION INTENDED
TO ENDURE FOR THE AGES.
THEY DID SET OUT SOME RULES.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO BE 35.
LEGISLATION HAS
TO PASS 2 HOUSES.
EACH STATE GETS TWO
SENATORS AND SO FORTH.
AND THOSE RULES CONGRESS CAN'T
MESS WITH NO MATTER HOW THE
WORLD CHANGES.
BUT FOR MOST ASPECTS
OF OUR GOVERNMENT,
THE FRAMERS SAID VERY LITTLE.
THEY MOSTLY LEFT
THE DETAILS BLANK,
AND THEY ADOPTED SOMETHING
CALLED THE NECESSARY AND PROPER
CLAUSE THAT GIVES
CONGRESS PRIMARY AUTHORITY
TO FILL IN THOSE BLANKS.
AND CHIEF JUSTICE MARSHALL'S
WORDS, QUOTE TO AVAIL ITSELF
OF EXPERIENCE, TO EXERCISE
ITS REASON, AND TO ACCOMMODATE
LEGISLATION TO
NEW CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT WAS TO BE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SPEAKING THROUGH CONGRESS
AND NOT THE JUSTICES WHO WERE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW, WHAT GOVERNMENT
MEASURES WERE APPROPRIATE AS
AMERICA PASSES INTO NEW AGES
AND NEW WORLDS.
SOMETHING LIKE THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE OR WHATEVER
THE NEXT INNOVATION MIGHT
BE OFFENDS SOME PARTICULAR
CONSTITUTIONAL TEXT OR
LONG STANDING PRACTICE.
IF CONGRESS WERE TO PASS A
LAW AUTHORIZING MATURE 34 YEAR
OLDS TO BECOME PRESIDENT, THEN
THE COURT CAN AND MUST SAY NO.
BUT IF THE COURT HAS LITTLE
MORE TO GO ON THAN ITS OWN SENSE
THAT THIS OR THAT ARRANGEMENT
IS TOO NOVEL, THAT IT GIVES
CONGRESS TOO MUCH POWER, OR IT
IS SOMETHING THAT THE FRAMERS
WOULD NOT HAVE COUNTENANCED
IN THE WORLD THAT THEY KNEW,
THEN THE COURT IS MAKING
A JUDGMENT CALL THAT THE
CONSTITUTION EXPLICITLY
RESERVES TO CONGRESS.
IN CASES LIKE SEBELIUS IT
IS PRECISELY THIS ALLOCATION
OF DECISION MAKING POWER
THAT SHOULD BE FOREMOST
IN THE COURT'S DELIBERATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL:
THANK YOU JOHN.
AND I DO HAVE TO SAY I DID SEE
YOU REACHING FOR THE SPINACH
QUICHE THIS MORNING.
AS YOU KNOW, WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO IS GO BACKWARDS AND FORWARDS
BETWEEN QUESTIONS
FROM AMONG OURSELVES,
AND ALSO QUESTIONS FROM YOU.
THERE ARE NOTE CARDS IF YOU
HAVE ANY PLEASE PASS THEM
ALONG AND SOMEBODY WILL
COME AND PICK THEM.
RAISE YOUR HAND.
AND THE PEOPLE AT THE
BACK, IF YOU CAN'T HEAR,
PLEASE WAVE LIKE CRAZY
AND WE'LL TRY TO FIX THAT.
I HAVE ONE QUESTION, AND ANY OF
THE THREE OF YOU CAN ANSWER IT.
ONE OF THE POINTS THAT JOHN
MADE IS THAT THIS COURT,
THE ROBERTS COURT HAS BEEN
SECOND GUESSING CONGRESS' POWER
TO A REMARKABLE EXTENT.
IS THIS NEW?
I MEAN FOR THOSE OF US WHO
THINK ABOUT THE PRE NEW DEAL,
IS THIS A DIFFERENT
WAY THAT THE COURT
IS VIEWING ITS RELATIONSHIP
WITH ANOTHER BRANCH?
MICHAEL?
IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO TALK, LAUREN.
>> MICHAEL KLARMAN: IT'S
NEW, BUT IT'S NOT BRAND NEW.
THE SUPREME COURT
RARELY CHALLENGE
CONGRESSIONAL LEGISLATION
IN THE 19TH CENTURY.
THEY STRUCK DOWN A STATUTE
IN MARBURY VS. MADISON,
THE FIRST CASE TO DECLARE
THE POWER OF JUDICIAL REVIEW.
THEY DIDN'T STRIKE DOWN ANOTHER
FEDERAL STATUTE UNTIL DRED
SCOTT.
THE INFAMOUS CASE OF
CONGRESS TRYING TO
KEEP SLAVERY OUT OF THE
MISSOURI COMPROMISE TERRITORY.
THE TERRITORY ACQUIRED IN
THE LOUISIANA PURCHASE.
BUT CONGRESS, THE COURT RARELY
STRUCK DOWN CONGRESSIONAL
LEGISLATION UNTIL
THE 20TH CENTURY.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HAS HAPPENED
FAIRLY REGULARLY IN THE LAST 40
YEARS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S DISTINCTIVE
TO THE ROBERTS COURT.
>> MARGARET MARSHALL:
OTHER COMMENTS?
>> WHAT'S ALWAYS INTRIGUED ME
ABOUT THE CHIEF JUSTICE'S ROLE
IN SEBELIUS IN WHAT MOTIVATED
HIM TO BOTH GRATUITOUSLY
EXPRESS HIS VIEWS ON
THE COMMERCE CLAUSE,
AND JUSTICE GINSBURG WROTE A
FABULOUS DISSENTING OPINION ON
THAT CASE.
POINTING OUT THAT ENITRE
COMMERCE CLAUSE DISPOSITION
WAS GRATUITOUS.
WHAT MOTIVATED HIM TO DO THAT
AND THEN TO PULL BACK AND FIND
A DEUS EX MACHINA IN THE
FORM OF THE TAX POWER
TO SAVE THE STATUTE AND
MAYBE SAVE THE COURT.
I DON'T KNOW, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I FIND IT A PUZZLE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: ALSO KNOWN
AS TAKING THE 5TH AMENDMENT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THERE'S ONE PERSON IN THIS
TENT WHO KNOWS THE ANSWER AND
SHE'S NOT TELLING US.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: ON
THAT NOTE, MS. GREENHOUSE,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED WITH YOUR CASE?
PARENTS INVOLVED.
>> OKAY, I HAVE LESS OF A FORMAL
ACADEMIC PRESENTATION THAN JOHN
DID.
BUT WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY
IS NOT DISCONNECTED FROM HIS
PRESENTATION.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE DETAILS OF THE CASE.
I URGE YOU TO READ MY
CAREFULLY WRITTEN LITTLE
SUMMARY IN THIS BLUE BOOKLET.
EXAMPLE OF JUDICIAL
ACTIVISM IN ANOTHER FRAME.
THIS WASN'T THE COURT
AGAINST CONGRESS.
THIS WAS THE COURT AGAINST LOCAL
CONTROL OF THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THE ROBERTS COURT HAS
HAD MAYBE 700 DECISIONS
ON THE MERITS IN THE 10 YEARS.
ADN THE WAY THIS
PANEL WAS ORGANIZED
WAS THAT CHIEF JUSTICE
MARSHALL INVITED EACH OF US
TO SELECT ONE CASE
TO TALK ABOUT.
SO WHY DID I CHOOSE
PARENTS INVOLVED?
I CHOSE IT BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
VERY EMBLEMATIC OF A DISTURBING
ASPECT OF THE ROBERTS COURT.
I HATE TO USE THE
CLICHED WORD ACTIVISM.
IT WAS ASSERTION OF JURISDICTION
BY THE COURT TO EVEN DECIDE
THIS CASE.
SO YOU KNOW THE BASIC METRIC
THAT THE COURT APPLIES IN
DECIDING WHETHER IT SHOULD
EXERCISE ITS ALMOST COMPLETE
DISCRETION ON WHAT TO DECIDE
IS WHETHER THERE'S A CASE THAT
PRESENTS A CONFLICT
AMONG THE LOWER
COURTS ON AN IMPORTANT
MATTER OF FEDERAL LAW.
THERE ACTUALLY WAS NO CONFLICT
ON THE QUESTION OF WHETHER A
SCHOOL BOARD SEEKING TO PRESERVE
INTEGRATION, NOT TO PRESERVE
SEGREGATION, TO PRESERVE THE
HARD WON GAINS OF INTEGRATION
ACHIEVED THROUGH STRUGGLE
AND FEDERAL COURT SUPERVISION
AND IN THESE CASES
BUSING ORDERS AND SO ON.
THEY FINALLY GET A MEASURE
OF INTEGRATION AND THEY
WANT TO KEEP IT.
AND THERE ARE RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING PATTERNS THAT MAKE IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO KEEP IT.
THERE ARE SOCIAL TRENDS
THAT MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT TO KEEP IT.
SO IN THIS CASE, BOTH THE
CITY, AND THE SCHOOL BOARD
OF LOUISVILLE, KENTUCKY.
OF COURSE ONCE A
SEGREGATED CITY.
AND THE SCHOOL BOARD
OF SEATTLE, WASHINGTON.
NEVER SEGREGATED.
BUT HIGHLY RACIALLY
ISOLATED SCHOOLS BECAUSE
OF HOUSING PATTERNS HAD
BEEN UNDER COURT ORDERS
FOR MANY YEARS.
DECIDED THAT IN MODEST WAYS IN
TERMS OF STUDENTS DECIDING THAT
THEY WANTED TO TRANSFER FROM ONE
SCHOOL TO ANOTHER, OR CHOOSING
ONE HIGH SCHOOL OR ANOTHER
HIGH SCHOOL, THE SCHOOL BOARD
WAS ENTITLED TO TAKE RACE
INTO ACCOUNT TO PRESERVE,
TO PREVENT A RETURN TO
RACIALLY ISOLATED SCHOOLS
AND CLASSROOMS.
THIS ISSUE HAS COME
UP AROUND THE COUNTRY,
AND THE LOWER COURTS ALL
AGREED THIS WAS SOMETHING
THAT SCHOOL BOARDS COULD CHOOSE
TO DO FOR THIS BENIGN PURPOSE.
BEFORE JUSTICE O'CONNOR
LEFT THE COURT IN LATE 2005,
SUCH A CASE CAME UP TO
THE COURT FROM THIS REGION
TO THE FIRST CIRCUIT, AND THE
COURT DECIDED NOT TO HEAR IT.
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T MEET THE
USUAL TESTS OF CONFLICT IN THE
CIRCUIT.
AS SOON AS O'CONNOR LEFT
THE COURT, IN EARLY 2006,
THESE TWO CASES MADE THEIR
WAY ONTO THE COURT'S DOCKET.
AND THE COURT DECIDED EVEN
THOUGH IT DIDN'T MEET THE USUAL
CHARACTERISTICS
FOR A WORTHY CASE,
THE COURT DECIDED TO TAKE IT.
WHAT DID THEY DECIDE?
IN AN OPINION FOR FOUR JUSTICES
BY CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
THE COURT SAID THIS IS
BASICALLY JUST BROWN VS.
BOARD OF EDUCATION
FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
THIS IS GOVERNMENT
COUNTING BY RACE.
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
THE CITIES OF
LOUISVILLE AND SEATTLE
HAD NO COMPELLING INTEREST.
AND COMPELLING
INTEREST IS THE TEST
FOR UNDER THE 14TH AMENDMENT'S
EQUAL PROTECTION GUARANTEE
WHERE THE GOVERNMENT CAN JUSTIFY
CLASSIFYING PEOPLE BY RACE.
THERE'S NO COMPELLING INTEREST
IN PRESERVING INTEGRATION.
HE WROTE FOR ONLY 4
BECAUSE JUSTICE KENNEDY
WHO AGREED WITH THE OUTCOME,
AND IN FACT HAS NEVER VOTED TO
UPHOLD ANY RACIAL CATEGORIZATION
ON THE PART OF THE SUPREME
COURT SAID ACTUALLY IT'S
A LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED
THAN THAT.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THE LINE WITH
WHICH CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS
ENDED HIS OPINION.
HE SAID THE WAY TO GET
BEYOND RACIAL DISCRIMINATING
ON THE BASIS OF RACE IS
TO STOP DISCRIMINATING ON
THE BASIS OF RACE.
THAT'S VERY DEEP AND PROFOUND.
[LAUGHTER]
AND JUSTICE KENNEDY SAID IT'S
A LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED
THAN THAT.
HE SAID OF COURSE THE CITIES OF
LOUISVILLE AND SEATTLE HAVE A
COMPELLING INTEREST IN
PRESERVING INTEGRATION.
OBVIOUSLY THEY DO.
THE PROBLEM THAT JUSTICE KENNEDY
FOUND WITH THESE PLANS IS HE
SAID THEY WEREN'T SUFFICIENTLY
NARROWLY TAILORED.
NARROW TAILORING IS
THE OTHER MAIN ASPECT
OF THE 14TH AMENDMENT ANALYSIS.
THEY WEREN'T SUFFICIENTLY
NARROWLY TAILORED TO MEET THE
EQUAL PROTECTION DEMANDS
OF THE 14TH AMENDMENT.
BY THAT HE MEANT THERE
WERE OTHER THINGS
THAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
MIGHT HAVE DONE OTHER
THAN CATEGORIZING STUDENTS
ON THE BASIS OF RACE.
A QUESTION OF WHERE SCHOOL
DISTRICT LINES WERE DRAWN OR
SCHOOLS WITH SPECIAL PROGRAMS
THAT COULD ATTRACT PEOPLE
AND SO ON AND SO ON.
WHETHER THAT'S AT ALL REALISTIC
ON THE GROUND I'M NOT IN A
POSITION TO SAY.
BUT IT WAS VERY INTERESTING.
SO THE OTHER THING
THAT INTERESTS ME
ABOUT THE CASE OTHER
THAN THE SHEER ACTIVISM
OF TAKING IT IS THAT THE CHIEF
JUSTICE WAS SO DETERMINED TO
SAY WHAT HE WANTED TO SAY.
TO USE THE CASE FOR
THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH
HE WANTED TO USE IT AND
SAY NO COMPELLING INTEREST.
AND THIS IS JUST BACKWARD
BROWN VS. BOARD OF EDUCATION,
HE WASN'T WILLING TO MEET
JUSTICE KENNEDY WHERE JUSTICE
KENNEDY WAS.
ALL HE WOULD HAVE HAD TO SAY WAS
WE DON'T HAVE TO DECIDE IF THIS
IS WHAT HE WANTED TO SAY IS WE
DON'T HAVE TO DECIDE IF THERE
IS A COMPELLING INTEREST.
ALL WE HAVE TO FIND
IS THAT THIS REMEDY
IS NOT NARROWLY TAILORED
TO SERVE THAT INTEREST.
THAT WOULD HAVE LET HIM
SPEAK FOR A MAJORITY.
IT WOULD HAVE NOT DECIDED
THE MOST PROFOUND ISSUE
IN THE CASE.
AND SO THIS WAS EARLY
IN THE ROBERTS COURT.
IT WAS A 2007 DECISION.
AND I THINK IT WAS A
RATHER DISTURBING EARLY
INDICATION OF HOW HE SAW HIS
ROLE IN BOTH CARRYING OUT
WHAT I CALL A ROBERTS PROJECT ON
RACE, ON GETTING THE GOVERNMENT
OUT OF THE BUSINESS OF COUNTING
BY RACE FOR ANY REASON.
AND SHELBY COUNTY, THE
VOTING RIGHTS ACT CASE
IS NOT ONE OF OUR CASES.
BUT THAT WAS A MAJOR ONE.
IT DISABLED APPLICATION OF THE
HEART OF THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
BUT ALSO HIS
UNWILLINGNESS TO BEND
A LITTLE BIT TO MEET JUSTICE
KENNEDY WHERE JUSTICE
KENNEDY WAS.
I'LL CONCLUDE BY SAYING THAT IN
THE INTERVENING YEARS, IN 2015,
BECAUSE THIS WAS ALL
THE WAY BACK IN 2007,
I'M NOT SURE WE WOULD SEE THE
SAME BEHAVIOR FROM JOHN ROBERTS
TODAY.
THIS SOUNDS CONDESCENDING, AND
I DON'T MEAN FOR IT TO SOUND
CONDESCENDING, I
RESPECT THE MAN.
HE HAS MATURED IN HIS ROLE
AS CHIEF JUSTICE AND I THINK
SEES THE VIRTUE OF NOT HAVING TO
WIN EVERY CASE THAT HE CAN WIN.
OR IN THIS CASE HE DIDN'T WIN ON
THE COMPELLING INTEREST POINT.
BUT RATHER TRY TO WORK
A BIT OF A COMPROMISE.
I THINK WE HAVE SEEN
THAT IN RECENT YEARS
IN VERY FASCINATING WAYS.
INCLUDING JUST LAST
TERM, THE CASE THAT
STRUCK DOWN THE BUBBLE
ZONE AROUND THE ABORTION
CLINICS IN MASSACHUSETTS LAW.
HE WROTE A QUITE TEMPERED
OPINION THAT ALLOWED JUSTICE
GINSBURG AND OTHERS
TO JOIN HIS OPINION.
I DON'T THINK WE WOULD HAVE
SEEN THAT FROM THE EARLIER CHIEF
JUSTICE ROBERTS.
THAT'S WHY I CHOSE
PARENTS INVOLVED.
THAT'S WHY IT'S A CASE
WORTH THINKING ABOUT
AND KEEPING IN MIND AS THE
ROBERTS COURT GOES FORWARD.
>> THANK YOU LINDA.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: SO
LINDA, JUST TO REASSURE YOU,
I HOPE THAT ALL CHIEF JUSTICES
MATURE AS THEY GO ALONG.
[LAUGHTER]
I WANT TO TELL YOU SOME
OF MY EARLY OPINIONS,
BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
TELL YOU WHICH ONES.
[LAUGHTER]
ONE OF THE THINGS THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT DOES
IS IT TELLS OTHER
FEDERAL COURTS.
I HATE TO USE THE TERM LOWER
FEDERAL COURTS, BUT WE OFTEN
CALL THEM LOWER FEDERAL
COURTS, WHAT TO DO.
HAVE THERE BEEN
CASES WHERE YOU CAN
SEE THE FEDERAL COURTS
BECOMING MORE ACTIVE
BASED ON PARENTS INVOLVED?
>> LINDA GREENHOUSE:
NO, I WONDERED.
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: YOU
MENTIONED THE VOTING CASE.
BUT JUST WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS?
>> LINDA GREENHOUSE: YEAH.
NO, I DON'T HAVE A
GOOD ANSWER FOR THAT.
I HAVEN'T SEEN OTHER PARENTS
INVOLVED TYPE CASES MAKING
THERE WAY THROUGH THE SYSTEM.
MY IMPRESSION IS THAT THINGS ARE
GETTING WORKED OUT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WITHOUT NECCESARILY
GOING TO COURT.
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE FINAL
WORD ON AT ALL IS THE GENERAL
QUESTION OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
IN HIGHER EDUCATION THERE'S
A CASE PENDING ON THE
COURT'S DOCKET THAT
WE'LL HEAR ABOUT ANY DAY.
WHETHER THE COURT IS GOING
TO GET INTO FISHER VS.
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION CASE,
WHICH THEY COULDN'T QUITE
DECIDE TWO YEARS AGO,
SENT BACK TO THE LOWER COURT.
THE LOWER COURT SAID YEAH WE
KIND OF STANDBY WHAT WE SAID
BEFORE.
SO THAT'S A BIG OPEN
QUESTION WHETHER
THE COURT IS GOING TO
GET BACK INTO THAT.
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: SURE.
YOU TALKED, YOU SELECTED THIS
COURT AS A WAY OF INDICATING
THAT AT LEAST THE CHIEF
JUSTICE, IF NOT THE COURT,
WILL SORT OF REACH OUT AND
BEND SOME OF THE JURISDICTIONAL
RULES PERHAPS OR NOT LOOK AT
THE WAY THEY USUALLY TAKE CASES
AS AN EXAMPLE OF
AN ACTIVIST CASE.
AND YOU MENTIONED THE CHIEF
JUSTICE'S PROJECT ON RACE.
ARE THERE OTHER CASES LAUREN OR
MIKE WHERE YOU THINK SHOW ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER WHAT
HIS VIEW ON RACE IS?
>> LAUREN SUDEALL LUCAS:
NOT TO HIJACK YOUR QUESTION,
BUT TO RESPOND TO THAT
QUESTION ALSO ABOUT THE IMPACT,
THERE'S THE PRESIDENTIAL IMPACT,
BUT I THINK THERE'S ALSO THE
QUESTION OF SYMBOLIC IMPACT.
BROWN VS. THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION IS ARGUABLY ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT CASE THAT
THE SPREME COURT HAS DECIDED
FROM A SYMBOLIC PERSPECTIVE.
IN PARENTS INVOLVED, TO TAKE
A CASE THAT IMPORTANT AND SORT
OF REDEPLOY IT IN A WAY THAT'S
VERY DIFFERENT FROM I THINK
MANY WILL SEE THE INTENTION
OF BROWN IS REALLY QUITE
SOMETHING.
AND THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN THE
OTHER OPINIONS IN THAT CASE
IS REALLY STARTLING, AS WELL.
YOU HAVE JUSTICE
THOMAS COMPARING
WHAT THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN LOUISVILLE AND SEATTLE
ARE DOING TO WHAT THE
SEGREGATIONISTS DID IN 1954.
TO MAKE THOSE COMPARISONS, ITS
SORT OF DIVORCED FROM INTENTION
AND HISTORICAL CONTEXT,
IT'S REALLY HARD
TO GET ONE'S MIND AROUND.
AND THE LINE THAT
LINDA MENTIONED,
THE WAY TO STOP DISCRIMINATION
ON THE BASIS OF RACE
IS TO STOP DISCRIMINATING
ON THE BASIS OF RACE.
I THOUGHT JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR
HAS SUCH AN ELOQUENT RESPONSE 7
YEARS LATER WHEN SHE
SAID THE WAY TO STOP
DISCRIMINATING ON
THE BASIS OF RACE
IS TO SPEAK OPENLY AND CANDIDLY
ABOUT RACE AND TO APPLY
THE CONSTITUTION WITH EYES
OPEN TO THE UNFORTUNATE
EFFECTS OF CENTURIES OF
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION.
[APPLAUSE]
SO I THINK PARENTS INVOLVED
HAD A VERY IMPORTANT SYMBOLIC
IMPORTANCE.
IT HASN'T BEEN CITED, IT STILL
HAD AN INDIRECT INFLUENCE BOTH
ON THE COURTS AND ALSO THE
PUBLIC AND THE WAY WE THINK
ABOUT RACE MORE BROADLY.
>> MICHAEL KLARMAN:
I AGREE WITH THAT.
I WANT TO ADD SOMETHING.
LINDA'S POINT IS IT
PROCEDURALLY ACTIVIST
FOR THE COURT TO RESOLVE
THIS QUESTION WHEN
THERE WAS NO PRESSING NEED.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND ITS SUBSTANTIVELY
ACTIVIST.
THE CONSERVATIVE
JUSTICES WHO ARE
THE ONES WHO WOULD INSIST THAT
THE CONSTITUTION SHOULD BE
COLOR BLIND ARE THE ONES WHO
WOULD CRITICIZE THE COURT IF IT
STRUCK DOWN AN ABORTION
RESTRICTION OR PERHAPS
IF THE COURT RULES IN
FAVOR OF GAY MARRIAGE,
THEY WOULD ACCUSE THE COURT
OF BEING ACTIVISTS FOR READING
THE CONSTITUTION IN A WAY
THAT INTENDED BY THE PEOPLE
WHO WROTE IT.
BUT IT TURNS OUT THAT
THE 14TH AMENDMENT
WAS NOT CLEARLY INTENDED
TO EMBRACE COLOR BLINDNESS.
THERE IS NO GOOD HISTORICAL
ARGUMENT THAT THAT'S WHAT THE
PEOPLE WHO WROTE THE
14TH AMENDMENT INTENDED.
AND THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
TEXT OF THE 14TH AMENDMENT THAT
TALKS ABOUT RACE SOME HOW
BEING OFF LIMITS TO GOVERNMENT
CLASSIFICATION.
THE PEOPLE WHO WROTE
IT IRONICALLY WERE TOO
RACIST TO ACTUALLY SUPPORT A
BAN ON RACE CLASSIFICATIONS.
THEY SAID REPEATEDLY WHEN THEY
WERE ADOPTING THE AMENDMENT
THAT THIS DOESN'T MANDATE
THAT YOU ENFRANCHISE BLACKS OR
MANDATE THAT YOU END
SCHOOL SEGREGATION.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
THE CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES,
IF THE TEXT OF THE CONSTITUTION
DOESN'T RULE OUT ANY PARTICULAR
POLICY, AND THE ORIGINAL
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT TEXT
DOESN'T CLEARLY RULE OUT
A PARTICULAR POLICY THEN
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DEFER TO
DEMOCRACY AND DEFER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
AND AS LINDA WAS SAYING,
THIS IS AS LOCAL AS IT GETS.
THIS IS A LOCAL SCHOOL BOARD
ADOPTING AN INTEGRATIONIST
POLICY.
THIS IS ACTIVISM NOT
JUST PROCEDURALLY BUT ITS
SUBSTANTIVE ACTIVISM
FROM THE RIGHT.
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: GOOD.
OKAY.
[APPLAUSE]
LINDA, LAST WORD, OR
YOU'VE HAD YOUR SAY?
OKAY.
LAUREN, SO AGAIN LINDA
SAID WE ASKED EACH OF THEM
TO SELECT ONE OPINION OF THE TEN
YEARS THAT INDICATED SOMETHING
IMPORTANT.
LAUREN?
>> LAUREN SUDEALL
LUCAS: THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN DEAN COHEN
AND THE RADCLIFFE INSTITUTE
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
THE CASE THAT I
CHOOSE TO DISCUSS
FOR MY PORTION OF THE DISCUSSION
IS ASHCROFT VS. IQBAL.
TO MANY OF YOU THIS CASE MAY
NOT BE AS FAMILIAR BECAUSE IT
WASN'T ONE THAT RECEIVED A LOT
OF ATTENTION FROM THE MEDIA.
OR AT LEAST NOT AS MUCH AS
SOME OF THE OTHER CASES.
BUT IT IS REALY
IMPORTANT IN PART BECAUSE
IT REPRESENTS AN EMERGING THEME
OF THE ROBERTS COURT WHICH
IS DEFINING THE ROLE THE COURT
PLAYS IN MUCH NARROWER TERMS
AND RESTRICTING
PLAINTIFFS ACCESS
TO THE COURTS AND
ACCESS TO JUSTICE,
PARTICULARLY FOR INDIVIDUAL
AND PRO SLAVE PLAINTIFFS.
THE CASES THAT MY CO-PANELISTS
TODAY HAVE DISCUSSED TODAY
HIGHLIGHT FOR GOOD REASONS
SOME OF THE LARGER SOCIAL
AND POLITICAL ISSUES THAT THE
COURT HAS CONFRONTED OVER THE
LAST DECADE.
A LOT OF THE CASES THAT THE
COURT HEARS HOWEVER INVOLVE
PROCEDURAL AND
JURISDICTIONAL QUESTIONS THAT
AREN'T PARTICULARLY EXCITING
AND DON'T ATTRACT A LOT OF
ATTENTION OUTSIDE LEGAL CIRCLES.
BUT THEY GO TO THE
DEEPER IMPORTANT QUESTION
OF WHETHER A COURT CAN ENTERTAIN
A CLAIM AND WHO CAN ASSERT SUCH
A CLAIM.
THESE QUESTIONS ARE PRECURSORS
THAT WE HAVE TO ANSWER BEFORE
WE CAN GET TO CASES LIKE
SEBELIUS OR PARENTS INVOLVED.
IN ADDRESSING THESE QUESTIONS,
ALTHOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
ANOMALIES, THE ROBERTS COURT HAS
OFTEN ACTED TO RESTRICT ACCESS
TO THE COURTS.
TO PROVIDE A FEW EXAMPLES IN
WHICH THE ROBERTS COURT HAS
ALREADY HAD AN IMPACT.
FIRST THE ROBERTS COURT HAS
BROADLY INTERPRETED ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS TO PREVENT INJURED
INDIVIDUALS FROM GOING TO
COURT, INSTEAD CHANNELING
THEM INTO ARBITRATION
AND RESTRICTING THEIR
ABILITY TO VINDICATE
THEIR RIGHTS IN THAT CONTEXT.
AND THE COURT HAS PREVENTED
HABEUS PETITIONERS
WHO PRESENTING NEW EVIDENCE
IN FEDERAL COURT EVEN EVIDENCE
REGARDING ACTUAL INNOCENCE
OR PROSECUTORIAL MISCONDUCT
HAS OCCURED.
INSTEAD THEY'RE LIMITED TO THE
RECORD AS IT EXISTED IN THE
STATE COURT.
THE COURT HAS
LIMITED THE INSTANCES
IN WHICH INDIVIDUALS CAN
SUE STATES IN FEDERAL COURT
TO CHALLENGE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
STATE ACTION.
THERE ARE OTHER EXAMPLES AND
THE LAST THAT I'LL MENTION AND
WE'RE FOCUSED ON TODAY IS THAT
THE COURT HAS RAISED THE BAR
FOR WHAT A PLAINTIFF HAS
TO ALLEGE AT THE OUTSET OF
LITIGATION IN ORDER TO AVOID
BEING THROWN OUT OF COURT
ALTOGETHER.
IQBAL AS THE DESCRIPTION
IN YOUR PROGRAM SAYS
AROSE IN THE WAKE OF 911, IQBAL
WAS CHALLENGING HIS TREATMENT
BY THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
WHILE HE WAS BEING DETAINED.
THE COURT NEVER
REACHED THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER HIS TREATMENT WAS
ACTUALLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
INSTEAD THE PRECURSOR QUESTION
AND THE ONLY QUESTION THE COURT
DID ANSWER WAS WHETHER
HE HAD ALLEGED SUFFICIENT
FACTS IN HIS COMPLAINT TO
SURVIVE A MOTION TO DISMISS.
FOR THOSE WHO AREN'T LAWYERS,
WHEN A PLAINTIFF WISHES TO
INITIATE A LAWSUIT
IN FEDERAL COURT,
INITIALLY SHE FILES A COMPLAINT.
AND THEN YOU WOULD
PROGRESS TO DISCOVERY
WHERE THE TWO SIDES WOULD
EXCHANGE INFORMATION,
AND THEN, AT LEAST IN THEORY,
LEAD POTENTIALLY TO TRIAL.
THESE CASES ARE ABOUT
THE TRANSITION FROM THAT
FIRST TO THAT SECOND STEP.
HAD THE PLAINTIFF DONE
ENOUGH OF PRESENTED ENOUGH
IN HER COMPLAINT TO JUSTIFY
MOVING ONTO DISCOVERY.
SO THE FEDERAL RULES OF
OFFICIAL PROCEDURE STATE
THAT A COMPLAINANT MUST
PROVIDE A SHORT AND PLAIN
STATEMENT OF THE CLAIM.
SHOWING THAT THE PLEADER
IS ENTITLED TO RELIEF.
FOR DECADES THIS WAS UNDERSTOOD
TO BE A FAIRLY LENIENT
STANDARD, JUST PUTTING THE OTHER
SIDE ON NOTICE OF THE CLAIM,
WAS OFTEN REFERRED TO
AS NOTICE PLEADING.
JUST GIVING THEM A
HEADS UP OF WHAT WOULD
BE INVOLVED IN THE LITIGATION.
TWO YEARS BEFORE IQBAL IN A
CASE OF BELL ATLANTIC CORP. VS.
TWOMBLY, THE COURT
RAISED THAT STANDARD
IN AN ANTITRUST CONTEXT
BUT IT WASNT CLEAR
IF IT WOULD BE APPLIED
BEYOND THAT CONTEXT.
IN TWOMBLY, THE COURT SAID THAT
HAD THE JUDGE DETERMINED AT THE
OUTSET OF THE CASE,
WHETHER THERE'S
A PLAUSIBLE CLAIM FOR RELEIF.
SO INTERJECTING SOME JUDGMENT
THERE, NOT JUST PUTTIN GHTE
OTHER SIDE ON NOTICE,
BUT ALLOWING THE JUDGE
TO EXERCISE DISCRETION AS TO
WHY THIS IS REALLY PLAUSIBLE.
IQBAL TOOK A FURTHER STEP
MAKING SURE THAT STANDARD WOULD
APPLY TO ALL CIVIL
CASES IN FEDERAL COURT.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE, BEFORE
A PLAINTIFF'S ALLEGATIONS WERE
PRESUMED TO BE TRUE AND A
COMPLAINT WOULD BE DISMISSED
ONLY IF THERE WERE NO
SET OF FACTS THAT WOULD
ENTITLE THE PLAINTIFF TO RELIEF.
BUT IN IQBAL, THE STANDARD
PROVIDES LOWER COURTS
WITH MUCH GREATER JUDICIAL
DISCRETION AND IT'S REALLY A
VERY SUBJECTIVE DETERMINATION.
THE COURT SUGGESTED THAT A
REVIEWING COURT SHOULD DRAW ON
THEIR JUDICIAL EXPERIENCE AND
COMMON SENSE WHEN MAKING SUCH A
DETERMINATION, AND I'LL TOUCH
ON THAT LATER IN THE WAY
IT'S ALLOWED BIAS TO FILTER
INTO MAKING THE DETERMINATIONS
WHETHER A COMPLAINT, WHETHER
A CLAIM AND COMPLAINT IS
PLAUSIBLE.
THIS ALL MAY SEEM TECHNICAL.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PLEADING
STANDARDS AND COMPLAINTS.
WHY DOES IT MATTER?
IQBAL WAS CITED MORE THAN
500 TIMES IN THE 2 MONTHS
FOLLOWING THE DECISION.
JUST 8 MONTHS LATER, IN
8,000 LOWER COURT CASES.
AT ONLY TWO YEARS
OLD, TWOMBLY WAS
ONE OF THE 5 MOST CITED COURT
CASES IN LOWER FEDERAL COURTS
IN ALL OF AMERICAN HISTORY.
THEY REALLY GRASPED ON
THIS AS IMPORTANT AND THEN
IT'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING
THAT THEY SHOULD BE
FOLLOWING AND ACCESSING
COMPLAINTS BEFORE THEM.
ONE PROMINENT SUPREME
COURT LITIGATOR
SAID IQBAL WAS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT SUPREME COURT
DECISION IN A DECADE FOR
DAY TO DAY LITIGATION
IN THE FEDERAL COURTS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF STUDIES
ACCESSING THE IMPACT THAT IT'S
HAD IN TERMS OF CLAIMS
BEING DISMISSED.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A FEW NUMBERS.
THE OVERALL RATE OF
DISMISSAL WENT FROM 61%
PRE TWOMBLY TO 72% IQBAL.
AND AN IMPACT HAS BEEN
FELT MORE STRONGLY
AND DEEPLY IN CASES INVOLVED
CIVIL RIGHTS DISCRIMINATION,
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION,
AND IN PRISON,
AND IN CASES INVOLVING PRO SE
PLAINTIFFS OR PLAINTIFFS THAT
ARE SERVING AS THEIR OWN LAYWER.
SO IN CIVIL RIGHTS
CASES THAT ARE PRO SE,
THE DISMISSAL RATE
WENT FROM 85% TO 92%.
IN PRISON CASES 67% TO 85% AND
IN EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
CASES WHERE THE PLAINTIFF WAS
REPRESENTED BY COUNCIL FROM
47% TO 65%.
ONE OF THE REASONS FOR
THIS UP TICK IN DISMISSALS
IS THAT OFTEN TO PROVE A CLAIM,
THE PLAINTIFF NEEDS INFORMATION
FROM THE OTHER SIDE.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN DISCRIMINATION
CASES WHERE YOU HAVE TO PROVE A
DISCRIMINATORY INTENT,
IT'S VERY HARD TO DO THAT,
PARTICULARLY FOR POOR OR PRO SE
LITIGANTS WHO AREN'T RESOURCED
AND DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO KNOW
WHAT WAS IN THE MIND OF THE
DISCRIMINATOR.
SO BY PREVENTING THEM FROM
GETTING TO THAT NEXT LEVEL OF
DISCOVERY, YOU'RE REALLY
DISABLING THEM FROM MAKING
THEIR CLAIM AND THE CLAIM
MAY NOT BE PLAUSIBLE BASED ON
WHAT'S IN THE COMPLAINT.
UNDER THE IQBAL STANDARDS
INDIVIDUALS HAVE
FARED WORSE THAN CORPORATIONS
OR THE GOVERNMENT AND THAT
ARGUABLY IS IN LINE WITH
WHAT OTHERS HAVE SAID
IS A TREND OF THE ROBERTS COURT
TO BE PRO CORPORATE OR PRO
BUSINESS.
AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS IDEA OF RELYING ON
JUDICIAL EXPERIENCE AND
COMMON SENSE, THAT PROVIDES AN
AVENUE FOR BIAS WHETHER
CONSCIENCE OR SUBCONSCIENCE TO
COLOR JUDGE'S CLAIMS
OF WHETHER JUDGES
ANALYSIS OF WHETHER PLAINTIFF'S
CLAIMS ARE PLAUSIBLE.
FOR BLACK PLAINTIFFS
CLAIMING RACE DISCRIMINATION,
THE DISMISSAL RATE
INCREASED FROM 20%
PRE TWOMBLY TO 54.6% AFTER IQBAL
AND WHITE JUDGES WERE TWO TIMES
AS LIKELY TO DISMISS THESE
CLAIMS AS BLACK JUDGES.
SO BY HAVING THIS MORE
SUBJECTIVE STANDARD,
YOU'RE REALLY ALLOWING THE
JUDGES TO HAVE MUCH GREATER
DISCRETION ABOUT WHETHER
SOMEONE CAN EVEN PROCEED,
NOT TO WHETHER THEY'LL WIN, BUT
JUST TO PROCEED TO DISCOVERY.
SOME OF ARGUES THAT THE TWOMBLY
STANDARD WAS NEVER MEANT
TO BE INTERPRETED IN THIS WAY.
ONE INTERESTING POINT
IS THAT JUSTICE SOUTER
WHO WROTE THE OPINION ON TWOMBLY
ACTUALLY DISSENTED IN IQBAL.
OTHERS LIKE JUSTICE STEVENS AND
JUSTICE GINSBURG HAVE PUSHED
BACK ON THE IMPOSITION OF A
HEIGHTENED PLEADING STANDARD
SAYING THAT THE IDEA BEHIND THE
FEDERAL RULES WAS NEVER TO KEEP
LITIGANTS OUT OF COURT,
BUT RATHER TO KEEP THEM IN.
I'LL JUST END BY SAYING THAT
ULTIMATELY AND PART OF THE
REASON WHY I CHOSE TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS CASE EVEN THOUGH IT
HASN'T RECEIVED AS MUCH
ATTENTION IS THAT DECISIONS
LIKE IQBAL ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND IMPACTFUL BECAUSE
THE RIGHTS IN THE CONSTITUTION
HAVE LITTLE MEANING IF THE
LITIGANTS LACK ACCESS IN THE
COURTS TO VINDICATE THEM.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL:
SO THANK YOU LAUREN.
I WONDER HOW MANY OF US REMEMBER
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
MADE US A DIFFERENT NATION
FROM ENGLAND IS WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT
TO GO TO COURT.
NOT SO IN ENGLAND.
IT'S VERY, VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO GET ACCESS TO COURT.
IT'S WRITTEN IN OUR CONSTITUTION
THAT YOU HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO GO TO COURT.
WHEN YOU THINK OF THAT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THIS DECISION,
IT'S PRETTY STUNNING.
I HAVE TO SAY LAUREN, I
DIDN'T KNOW THOSE STATS.
IT TELLS YOU WHAT HAPPENS, IF
YOU THINK OF THE QUESTION I
ASKED TO LINDA, HOW MANY CASES
FOLLOWED PARENTS UNITED AND YOU
CAN SEE IMMEDIATELY THE
IMPACT THTA IT'S HAD.
IT IS NOT TRUE THAT THE JUDGES
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE FEWER CASES.
ACTUALLY, WE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE FEWER CASES.
[LAUGHTER]
I CAN'T BUT HELP TO TAKE A
MOMENT NOW TO SAY SOMETHING
THAT I SAY ALMOST EVERY
GATHERING THAT I HAVE,
WHICH IS WHY WE FOCUS
APPROPRIATELY ON THE FEDERAL
COURTS AND OF COURSE ON THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
SO MANY CASES ARE
DECIDED IN OUR STATE
COURTS, WHICH ARE JUST
OVERWHELMED BY THE
NUMBER OF CASES.
AND ALTHOUGH WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
ON A DECISION LIKE THIS,
IT HAS ENORMOUS INFLUENCE
ON HOW WE DECIDE OUR CASES,
WHETHER WE DECIDE TO ADMIT
OR TO DISMISS A CASE.
AND SO THAT EXTRAORDINARY
ORTHOLOGY RIPPLED VERY QUICKLY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
MICHAEL OR LINDA?
COMMENTS?
YEAH, LINDA.
>> LINDA GREENHOUSE: JUST
ONE COMMENT, THE IQBAL CASE,
UNLIKE PARENTS INVOLVED, IT'S
NOT A CONSTITUTIONAL DECISION.
IT'S AN INTERPRETATION
OF THE FEDERAL RULES,
AND IT'S WITHIN THE POWER
OF CONGRESS TO CHANGE THAT.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN EFFORTS
TO PASS LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
REVERSE IQBAL AND RETURN TO THE
MORE LIBERAL PLEADING STANDARD.
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
HAVE EVER HEARD OF THIS CASE
BEFORE YOU CAME HERE?
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: THIS IS
A VERY EDUCATED AUDIENCE LINDA.
I WOULD HAVE PUT UP MY
HAND WHETHER OR NOT I HAD
HEARD OF THE CASE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> LINDA GREENHOUSE: YOU
KNOW, IF PEOPLE REALLY DID GET
ENERGIZED AND MADE IT
SOME KIND OF ISSUE,
WE DON'T HAVE TO LIVE WITH THIS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MICHAEL KLARMAN: I
WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
IT IS INTERESTING.
WE SORT OF ASSUME
THAT THE COURT IS
GOING TO DIVIDE FIVE TO FOUR ON
THESE BIG CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES
THAT CAPTURE THE HEADLINES
IN THE NEWSPAPER.
SO WE'RE NOT SURPRISED WHEN THE
COURT DIVIDES FIVE TO FOUR ON
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
CASES, ABORTION CASES,
DEATH PENALTY CASES.
BUT THERE ARE ACTUALLY
A WHOLE SERIES
OF CASES INVOLVING
ACCESS TO JUSTICE, WHICH
INVOLVE STATUTORY INTERPRETATION
ISSUES, INTERPRETING
THE FEDERAL RULES,
AND THE COURT TENDS
TO DIVIDE FIVE TO FOUR
ON THOSE, AS WELL.
AND THEY TEND TO BE CONSISTENT
FIVE TO FOUR DIVISIONS.
IT'S NOT A RANDON FIVE TO FOUR.
THERE TEND TO BE FOUR
CONSERVATIVES AND FOUR
LIBERALS, AND EVERYTHING DEPENDS
ON WHERE JUSTICE KENNEDY COMES
OUT, WITH UNUSUAL EXCEPTIONS
LIKE THE HEALTHCARE CASE.
I THINK WHAT THIS TELLS YOU
IS THERE'S A LOT OF ROOM
IN LAW FOR THE VALUE OF THE
JUDGES TO INFLUENCE THEIR
INTERPRETATIONS.
IT'S NOT TO SAY THAT LEGAL
INTERPRETATION IS NOTHING
BUT POLITICS, BUT
IT IS TO SAY IT
HAS A LOT TO DO WITH HOW
THESE THINGS ARE INTERPRETED.
AND THERE ARE STUDIES SHOWING,
AND THIS IS FOLLOWING UP
ON WHAT LAUREN SAID THAT ONE OF
THE CONSISTENT TAKEAWAY LINES
FROM THE ROBERTS COURT.
YOU CAN'T CHARACTERIZE IT
CONSTITUTIONALLY BECAUSE
JUSTICE KENNEDY
GOES BACK AND FORTH.
HE'S A LIBERAL ON
GAY RIGHTS ISSUES.
HE SOMETIMES A LIBERAL ON
ISSUES INVOLVING THE DEATH
PENALTY, SCHOOL PRAYER.
BUT HE'S CONSERVATIVE ON
CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND RACE
ISSUES.
BUT ON ISSUES INVOLVING ACCESS
TO JUSTICE AND SPECIFICALLY
ON THE ISSUES WHERE
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HAS EXPRESSED AN INTEREST.
THIS IS THE MOST PRO CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE COURT IN HISTORY.
AND THERE'S A STUDY
BY JUDGE POSNER AND A
COUPLE OF ACADEMICS SHOWING
THAT THE FIVE CONSERVATIVE
JUSTICES ARE FIVE OUT
OF THE TOP TEN MOST PRO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
JUSTICES IN HISTORY.
AND ROBERTS AND ALITO
ARE ONE AND TWO.
THESE DON'T GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION BUT THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
THE COURTS DECIMATING
ACCESS TO CLASS ACTION.
IT'S CUTBACK ON ACCESS TO
CONVENTIONAL CIVIL LITIGATION.
IT'S CONTRACTED
ANTITRUST LIABILITY.
THESE ARE A REALLY BIG DEAL AND
THEY JUST DON'T GET THE SAME
HEADLINES, AND THE OUTCOMES TEND
TO BE ALONG THE SAME POLITICAL
LINES THAT YOU WOULD FIND
IN CONSTITUTIONAL CASES.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: SO ONE
REASON WHY THEY MAY NOT BE
GETTING THE SAME
ATTENTION, MICHAEL,
IS BECAUSE LINDA GREENHOUSE
ISN'T WRITING REGULARLY FOR THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
IF THEY GET ANOTHER RADCLIFFE
GRADUATE DOING THAT,
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
ALTHOUGH I LOVE HER SUCCESSORS.
LAUREN, I'VE HAD WONDERFUL
QUESTIONS FROM THE AUDIENCE BUT
THIS ONE HAS COME UP
SUFFICIENTLY EARLY FOR ME TO BE
ABLE TO ASK YOU
WHILE YOU'RE HERE.
GIVEN THE SORT OF
TOUGHER STANDARDS
FOR BRINGING THE CASE, WILL THAT
HAVE ANY IMPACT ON THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE OPPOSED TO THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND HAVE
BROUGHT CASES CHALLENGING IT?
IS IT GOING TO MEAN
THAT THEY TOO ARE
GOING TO BE CUT OUT OF BEING
ABLE TO BRING THEIR CASES?
>> LAUREN SUDEALL LUCAS: I
SUPPOSE THAT IS ASKING ABOUT
THE STANDING QUESTION IN
THE CASE BEFORE THE COURT.
I ACTUALLY DIDN'T LIST
STANDING ON MY LIST OF AREAS,
BECAUSE I THINK THE ROBERTS
COURT HAS HAD MORE OF A MIXED
RECORD ON STANDING.
IN SOME CASES THEY HAVE
RESTRICTED STANDING,
IN THE CONTEXT OF
TAXPAYER STANDING AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT CLAUSE.
IN OTHER CONTEXTS THE
COURT HAS FOUND STANDING.
THE MORE CYNICAL MIGHT SAY THE
COURT FINDS STANDING WHEN IT
WANTS TO GET THE
MERITS OF THE CASE,
AND DOESN'T FIND STANDING
WHEN IT DOESN'T WANT TO,
OR AT LEAST WHEN FIVE MEMBERS
OF THE COURT DON'T WANT TO.
I'M NOT ONE TO
PREDICT OR FORECAST.
SO I DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
BUT I SUSPECT THAT THAT
CYNICAL VIEW MIGHT HAVE ONE
RESPONSE TO WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE CASE.
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: GREAT.
LINDA.
>> LINDA GREENHOUSE:
JUST TO PICK UP ON THAT.
A COUPLE OF THE
HOT BUTTON ISSUES
BEFORE THE COURT RECENTLY HAVE
PLAINTIFFS WHOSE STANDING BY
CONVENTIONAL
CONSERVATIVE METRICS IS
VERY SKETCHY TO SAY THE LEAST.
FOR INSTANCE, IN THE
FISHER AGAINST UNIVERSITY
OF TEXAS CASE,
MISS FISHER HAD BY
THE TIME CASE CAME UP ALREADY
GRADUATED FROM ANOTHER
UNIVERSITY.
SO THERE WAS NO REMEDY THAT
A COURT COULD AWARD HER.
THE CASE FAILED WHAT IS
CALLED THE REDRESS ABILITY
PRONG OF STANDING.
THAT WAS AN ISSUE, BUT THE
COURT JUST PROCEEDED, BECAUSE
AS LAUREN SAID THEY WANTED TO AT
LEAST TRY TO REACH THE MERITS.
THERE'S BEEN CHALLENGES TO THE
STANDARDS OF THE CURRENT REALLY
SKETCHY PLAINTIFFS IN THE
CURRENT AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
CASE.
THE CASE BEING TOTALLY
PHONY FROM THE GET GO,
BUT ALSO PHONY IN RECRUITING
THESE PLAINTIFFS WHO REALLY
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND ANYTHING
ABOUT THE CASE IT TURNS OUT.
AND ACTUALLY FAILED THE BASIC
PRONG OF THE STANDING DOCTRINE,
WHICH IS INJURY.
INJURY IN FACT BECAUSE THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS NOBODY
IS INJURED BY THE EXISTENCE
OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT.
THEY HAVE AN IDEOLOGICAL INJURY,
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE THE
LAW.
BUT THEY CANNOT ACTUALLY
PROVE A FINANCIAL INJURY.
BUT YET THE COURT,
LET'S ASSUME IS
GOING TO PRECEDE TO THE
MERITS ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: SO THAT
LEADS TO A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
THAT I'VE HAD AND I'M GOING TO
TRY AND COMBINE THEM WHICH HAVE
TO DO WITH JUDICIAL ACTIVISM.
SORT REACHING AT WHATEVER IT IS.
ONE WAY OF SAYING
THIS IS THERE A WAY
TO DIFFERENTIATE THE ROBERTS
COURT QUOTE JUDICIAL ACTIVISM
FROM THE EARLIER CRITICISM
OF LIBERAL JUDGES,
ESPECIALLY IN THE
WARREN COURT, OR
IS THIS ONLY A
QUESTION OF OX GORING?
OR IS THERE SOMETHING
ELSE AT WORK?
AND ANOTHER QUESTION IS SAYING
THE WARREN COURT WAS WIDELY
SEEN AS ACTIVIST FROM
A POSITION ON THE LEFT,
ON THE BASIS OF THE PRINCIPLES
OF EQUALITY AND LIBERTY.
THIS PANEL HAS CRITICIZED THE
ACTIVISM OF THE ROBERTS COURT.
WHAT PRINCIPLE DEFENSE
OF ITS ACTIVISM WOULD
BE MADE BY
CONSERVATIVE SUPPORTERS
OF THE ROBERTS COURT?
UNFORTUNATELY I SHOULD TELL
YOU THAT PROFESSOR MANNING,
A SITUATION AROSE
EARLIER THIS WEEK
THAT HE HAD TO LEAVE
FOR PERSONAL REASONS.
SO LINDA, LAUREN, MICHAEL,
PUT ON YOUR CONSERVATIVE HATS,
WHICH YOU DO WHEN YOU
TEACH YOUR LAW STUDENTS.
AND WHAT IS THE
BEST ARTICULATION
FOR WHAT THE ROBERTS
COURT IS DOING?
>> LINDA GREENHOUSE: NOT
TO CHANNEL JOHN MANNING.
BUT FROM THE CONSERVATIVE
PERSPECTIVE, THE WORD THAT THEY
USE NOW IS JUDICIAL ENGAGEMENT.
THAT JUDGES SHOULD BE
ENGAGED, SHOULD NOT STEP BACK
FROM THE FRAY.
SHOULD NOT USE BARRIERS
TOO, STANDING AND SO ON.
TO BRING THE COURT BACK.
BRING CONSTITUTIONAL
DOCTRINE AND DOCTRINES
OF STATUTORY INTERPRETATION
BACK TO WHERE THEY SHOULD ALWAYS
HAVE BEEN.
SO FOR INSTANCE IN THE
TYPE OF CASES THAT LAUREN
WAS TALKING ABOUT,
THERE HAS BEEN
A GREAT CONCERN ON THE
SIDE OF BUSINESS THAT A
LOT OF QUOTE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS
ARE MAKING THEIR WAY INTO
COURT.
AND EVEN THOUGH MANY OF
THEM HAVE GOTTEN DISMISSED
ULTIMATELY, THAT'S ONLY AFTER
THE DEFENDANT CORPORATION
HAS HAD TO SPEND TONS OF TIME
AND MONEY IN DISCOVERY AND ALL
THE PRE TRIAL STUFF.
SO IF THE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY ARE HIGHER AND THESE
CASES ARE GOTTEN RID
OF AT THE ENTRY POINT,
IT JUST SAVES EVERYBODY A
LOT OF TIME AND TROUBLE.
THAT'S CERTAINLY ONE ARGUMENT.
ON THE CONSTITUTIONAL SIDE.
SO JUSTICE KENNEDY WOULD SAY
I THINK AND JUST AS PEOPLE
KNOW, JUSTICE KENNEDY'S
BYWORD IS DIGNITY.
HE VIEWS IT AS AN
AFFRONT TO HUMAN
DIGNITY TO BE CLASSIFIED BY ONES
GOVERNMENT ON THE BASIS OF ONES
RACE.
THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
DOUBTS ABOUT THAT KIND
OF JURISPRUDENCE WOULD SAY
THAT'S TRUE AS FAR AS IT GOES.
BUT IT DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T PUT IT IN
THE CONTEXT OF WHAT'S THE
PURPOSE FOR THE CLASSIFICATION.
WHAT'S THE REMEDIAL
PURPOSE, OR WHAT'S
THE EVEN LARGER
DIGNITARY PURPOSE.
I THINK HE FEELS THAT VERY
STRONGLY, AND LIKEMINDED PEOPLE
FEEL THAT VERY
STRONGLY THAT IT'S
SIMPLY INAPPROPRIATE,
AND EVEN DANGEROUS
FOR THE GOVERNMENT TO
BE IN THAT BUSINESS.
I MAYBE HAVEN'T DONE A VERY GOOD
JOB OF CHANNELING CONSERVATIVES
BUT I THINK THAT'S WHAT
HE WAS GOING TO SAY.
>> LAUREN SUDEALL LUCAS: IT'S
INTERESTING THAT THE COURT
SEEMS SO WORRIED ABOUT LOWER
COURTS BEING FLOODED WITH
FRIVOLOUS CLAIMS AND THAT
SORT OF PRACTICAL ASPECT OF
LITIGATION.
AND AS AN ASIDE ONE FACT
THAT I DIDN'T MENTION IS THAT
THERE'S A STUDY THAT SAYS
THAT THE HEIGHTENED PLEADING
STANDARD THAT COMES OUT OF
IQBAL HASN'TACTUALLY RESULTED IN
HIGHER QUALITY CLAIMS
BASED ON ULTIMATE OUTCOME.
YOU SEE THIS INTERPLAY A
LOT BETWEEN THE MAJORITY
AND THE DISSENT,
NOT VERY CONCERNED
WITH THE PRACTICAL EFFECTS OF
RESTRICTING RIHGTS SO WHETHER
ITS CASES INVOLVING VOTER
IDENTIFICATION LAWS, ABORTION,
YOU OFTEN SEE THE DISSENTERS
SAYING, HEY, BUT LOOK AT HOW
THIS ACTUALLY AFFECTS
PEOPLE IN THEIR DAY
TO DAY LIVES, LOOK AT
HOW THIS AFFECTS POOR
PEOPLE, LOOK AT HOW THIS
AFFECTS MARGINALIZED PEOPLE.
AND THE COURT SEEMS GENERALLY
UNCONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU'RE OPERATING IN A VACUUM,
PERHAPS THIS SEEMS LIKE A
PURIST INTERPRETATION.
BUT IF YOU THINK ABOUT HOW THESE
DECISIONS ARE AFFECTING PEOPLE,
YOU SEE A LOT OF OPINIONS WHERE
THE DISSENT JUST CANNOT BELIEVE
THAT THE MAJORITY IS NOT
TAKING THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: THANK YOU.
I WAS GOING TO LET THEM JUST
TALK ABOUT THE CASES THAT THEY
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT.
BUT IT TURNS OUT A LOT OF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT ANOTHER
CASE.
NOT THE ONE THAT HASN'T
BEEN DECIDED YET.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT LATER.
BUT CITIZENS UNITED.
[APPLAUSE]
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THEY
JUST AVOIDED TALKING ABOUT IT.
BUT THEY DIDN'T.
BUT ANY WAY.
JUST A TON OF QUESTIONS UP HERE.
DO YOU THINK ANY OF THE JUSTICES
IN THE MAJORITY IN CITIZENS
UNITED SEE IT AS NOW A DISASTER
FOR AMERICAN DEMOCRACY?
WILL THE PANEL PLEASE
COMMENT ON CITIZENS UNITED?
OR I WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT CITIZENS UNITED.
OR CAN YOU PLEASE?
AND SO ON.
[LAUGHTER]
OKAY, MICHAEL.
PLEASE COMMENT ON
CITIZENS UNITED.
>> MICHAEL KLARMAN: SO THIS
ACTUALLY TIES IN REALLY WELL
WITH THE LAST QUESTION
ABOUT ACTIVISM.
AGAIN, IF YOU TAKE AS AN
EXAMPLE ABORTION REGULATION,
WHEN THE COURT STRIKES DOWN AN
ABORTION REGULATION, JUSTICE
SCALIA AND THOMAS WOULD SAY,
THE ORIGINAL UNDERSTANDING
OF THE 14TH AMENDMENT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH ABORTION.
THIS SHOULD BE LEFT UP TO
LEGISLATIVE REGULATION.
SO THE QUESTION IS, HOW DID
THE FIVE CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES
JUSTIFY STRIKING DOWN
A BAN ON CORPORATIONS,
MAKING INDEPENDENT SPEECH
STATEMENTS IN ELECTIONS?
AND THIS GETS BACK TO
MARGIE'S LAST QUESTION
WHICH IS HOW WOULD THEY
DEFEND THEMSELVES AGAINST THE
CHARGES OF ACTIVISM.
AND THE ANSWER IS THEY'LL
JUST SAY THE TEXT OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT TELLS YOU THAT SPEECH
IS SUPPOSED TO BE PROTECTED AND
IT DOESN'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT WHO THE SPEAKER IS.
BUT THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE,
WELL FIRST OF ALL THE FACT THAT
THE FIRST AMENDMENT TALKS
ABOUT THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH
DOESN'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT SPENDING MONEY.
THE PEOPLE WHO WROTE
THE FIRST AMENDMENT
HAD AN INCREDIBLY NARROW
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
WAS PROTECTED.
NONE OF THEM WOULD
HAVE DREAMED THAT
THE IDEA OF SPENDING MONEY ON
ELECTIONS WAS PROTECTED SPEECH.
WHEN CONGRESS PASSED
A SEDITION ACT
IN THE FIRST DECADE OF
THE COUNTRY'S HISTORY,
WHICH PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR
CRITICIZING JOHN ADAMS TOO
HARSHLY AS PRESIDENT.
NOT A SINGLE FEDERAL JUDGE IN
THE COUNTRY THOUGHT THAT LAW
WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE
THEY HAD SUCH A NARROW
VIEW OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
BUT THE CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES
WON'T TALK ABOUT THE ORIGINAL
UNDERSTANDING OF THE 1ST
AMENDMENT BECAUSE IT'S SO
STRONGLY AGAINST THEIR POSITION,
THEY JUST SAY THAT WE WON'T GET
TO THE ORIGINAL UNDERSTANDING,
BECAUSE THE FIRST AMENDMENT
TALKS ABOUT SPEECH AND
SPENDING MONEY IS SPEECH.
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OUTRAGEOUS BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT SAY WE OUGHT TO LOOK
AT ORIGINAL UNDERSTANDING AND
THERE'S REALLY NOT A SHRED OF
EVIDENCE ON THEIR SIDE ON THAT
ISSUE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL:
LAUREN, LINDA?
>> LINDA GREENHOUSE: WELL YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER ANY OF
THE CURRENT CITIZENS UNITED
MAJORITY ARE ABOUT TO
RECALIBRATE THEIR UNDERSTANDING.
THEY HAD THAT CHANCE QUITE
SOON AFTER THE DECISION.
A CASE CAME UP FROM MONTANA
WHERE THE MONTANA SUPREME COURT
IN THE KIND OF DEFIANCE OF
CITIZENS UNITED HAD UPHELD
STATE CORPORATE CAMPAIGN
SPENDING LIMITS UNDER THE STATE
CONSTITUTION.
AND MONTANA HAD A VERY
INTERESTING HISTORY WHERE
CORPORATIONS HAD BASICALLY
BOUGHT U.S. SENATORS
BACK IN THE DAY WHEN
SENATORS WERE APPOINTED BY
STATE LEGISLATURES.
SO THE MONTANA SUPREME COURT
SAID YOU KNOW WE'RE ACTING OUT
OF OUR OWN SPECIAL HISTORY.
AND WE HAVE THESE LAWS.
AND WE THINK WE
CAN MAKE THE CASE
THAT THE NOTION OF
CORRUPTION WHICH
IS AT THE HEART OF CITIZENS
UNITED, A VERY NARROW VIEW.
A QUID PRO QUO BASICALLY
BRIBERY, CORRUPTION.
THAT WE UNDERSTAND CORRUPTION
MORE DEEPLY AND THIS
IS WHAT WE THINK.
THE COURT OVERTURNED IT
EVEN WITHOUT AN OPINION.
OVERTURNED THE MONTANA
SUPREME COURT AND
SAID THAT STATE LAW
WAS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SO THAT WAS A CHANCE
TO EXPRESS A LITTLE
BIT OF BUYER'S REMORSE.
AND I DON'T SEE THAT ANYTHING
HAS COME THEIR WAY SINCE
THAT'S GOING TO, IF ANYTHING,
THEY'RE DRILLING DOWN BECAUSE
LAST TERM IN THE CASE
CALLED McCUTCHEON,
THE CHEIF JUSTICE WROTE THE
MAJORITY OPINION ERASE THE
LIMITS ON AGGREGATE INDIVIDUAL
POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS.
IT SEEMS THAT EVERY TIME THEY
GET A NEW CHANCE WHERE THEY
MIGHT PULL BACK A LITTLE,
INSTEAD THEY GO FURTHER.
>> LAUREN SUDEALL LUCAS: AND
CORPORATIONS NOT ONLY HAVE FREE
SPEECH RIGHTS, BUT THEY NOW
HAVE RELIGIOUS BELIEFS TOO.
SO THEY'RE BECOMING MORE
AND MORE LIKE PEOPLE.
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: OKAY.
I THINK THAT TOOK CARE OF
CITIZENS UNITED. [LAUGHTER]
THIS IS REALLY NOT ON POINT,
EXCEPT IT IS ON POINT.
QUITE OFTEN WHEN I'VE HAD WITH
JUSTICE SCALIA ON THIS POINT HE
SAYS I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE NEW YORK TIMES,
KNOWING VERY WELL THAT I WAS
MARRIED TO SOMEONE WHO WROTE TO
THE NEW YORK TIMES FOR 50 YEARS.
HE SAID I'D LIKE TO SEE THE
NEW YORK TIMES SAYI THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE FREE SPEECH
RIGHT TO CHARGE MONEY FOR THE
THEIR EDITORIALS, WAS
ESSENTIALLY HIS POSITION.
MY VIEW WAS THERE'S PROTECTION
OF THE PRESS, AS WELL.
IT'S NEVER BEEN A VERY ENGAGED
DISCUSSION, I HAVE TO SAY.
[LAUGHTER]
I DO WANT TO SAY ONE
ADDITIONAL THING.
ALMOST EVERYBODY WHO THINKS
ABOUT CITIZENS UNITED
THINKS ABOUT IT FROM THE
CONTEXT OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
AND ESPECIALLY
CONGRESSIONAL RACES,
OR LEGISLATIVE
RACES IN THE STATES.
THERE ARE MANY STATES
THAT HAVE ELECTED JUDGES.
37 STATES THAT HAVE
ELECTED JUDGES.
AND CITIZENS UNITED
APPLIES TO THOSE, AS WELL.
AND SOMETHING REALLY
TERRIBLE IS GOING ON
IN OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S NOW COSTING HUGE AMOUNTS
OF MONEY IN SOME OF THOSE RACES.
AND SOME OF THE BEST
JUDGES ARE SIMPLY NOT
AGREEING TO BECOME JUDGES OR
STEPPING AWAY FROM THE COURT.
MY MONTANA COLLEAGUES FELT VERY,
VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THAT CASE.
AND I THINK IN MONTANA,
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
AN AMICUS BRIEF FILED BY FORMER
CHIEF JUSTICES OF THE MONTANA
SUPREME COURT IN THAT CASE.
THEY KNOW VERY
WELL WHAT HAPPENS.
IT'S BAD ENOUGH PUTTING
MONEY INTO CONGRESSIONAL
AND PRESIDENTIAL RACES,
BUT IT HAS A VERY POWERFUL,
NEGATIVE IMPACT WHEN YOU PUT IT
INTO JUDICIAL RACES, AS WELL.
THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND.
[APPLAUSE]
PERHAPS AS A FINAL QUESTION
BEFORE WE TURN TO MICHAEL,
THERE'S A MOVEMENT
UNDER WAY NOW KIND OF.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN PERSUADE
THEM TO HAVE NEW JUSTICES
THAT ARE APPOINTED TO THE COURT
TO AGREE THAT THEY WILL STEP
ASIDE AFTER A PARTICULAR
PERIOD OF TIME.
IN OTHER WORDS IT GOES
TO THE LENGTH OF TENURE.
FEDERAL JUDGES, AS YOU
KNOW, SERVE FOR LIFE.
AT THE TIME THE
CONSTITUTION WAS WRITTEN.
THE APPROXIMATE
LIFE SPAN WAS 50.
SO MANY OF US ARE VERY HAPPY
THAT THERE'S BEEN MEDICAL
PROGRESS SINCE THAT TIME.
BUT IT HAS MEANT
THAT OUR JUSTICES ARE
SERVING FOR LONGER AND LONGER
AND LONGER PERIODS OF TIME.
THAT IS TRUE BY THE WAY FOR
THE ENTIRE FEDERAL SYSTEM,
NOT JUST FOR THE NINE JUSTICES
ON THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT.
BUT CONGRESS HAS CREATED
A MECHANISM WHICH MAKES IT
POSSIBLE FOR FEDERAL JUDGES
ON THE CIRCUIT COURTS AND THE
DISTRICT COURTS TO TAKE
WHAT'S CALLED SENIOR STATUS.
IT'S A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
WE DO AT UNIVERSITIES NOW AFTER
THEY PUT AN END TO 70 YEARS
A MANDATORY AGE RETIREMENT,
WHERE YOU CAN REMAIN FULL TIME
ACTING JUDGE OR PART TIME.
BUT YOU AUTOMATICALLY GET
ANOTHER JUDICIAL POSITION IN
YOUR COURT, THAT OF COURSE WE
CAN'T DO IN THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT, BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE NINE JUSTICES.
ANY VIEWS FROM ANY OF
YOU ABOUT WHETHER THAT'S
A GOOD OR BAD IDEA AND
WHAT'S THE LIKELIHOOD OF IT
SUCCEEDING?
AND MICHAEL, YOU
NEED NOT ANSWER,
BECAUSE YOUR JUSTICE
IS SITTING RIGHT HERE.
OR MAYBE YOU HAVE
A VERY STRONG VIEW.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MICHAEL KLARMAN: I HAD A
COUPLE STUDENTS WHO WROTE A
NOTE YEARS AGO AND THEIR
PROPOSAL WAS LIMITED TO THE
SUPREME COURT, BUT IT WOULD
BE 18 YEAR STAGGERED TERMS.
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS
A BRILLIANT PROPOSAL.
I DON'T THINK IT HAS ANY
PRACTICAL CHANCE OF BEING
ADOPTED, BUT IT WAS BRILLIANT
PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT SOLVES ALL
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT EXIST
WITH THE CURRENT SYSTEMS.
SO THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH
STRATEGIC APPOINTMENTS.
PRESIDENTS WILL APPOINT
PEOPLE YOUNGER AND YOUNGER,
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A PARTICULAR
VIEW REPRESENTED
AS LONG AS YOU CAN.
THERE ARE STRATEGIC RETIREMENTS.
JUSTICES WILL LEAVE
THE COURT WHEN
THERE'S A PRESIDENT SITTING WHO
THEY BELIEVE ROUGHLY REPRESENTS
THE VIEWS THEY WANT
WRITTEN INTO LAW.
THERE'S THE PROBLEM OF FORTUITY.
WILLIAM HOWARD TAFT
HAD 5 OR 6 APPOINTMENTS
IN ONE 4 YEAR PERIOD.
JIMMY CARTER HAD NONE DURING
HIS 4 YEAR TERN IN OFFICE.
AND IT'S A MANDATORY
RETIREMENT, WHICH
WE HAVE IN MOST AREAS OF LIFE,
AND IT SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD
PROBABLY BE A PRETTY GOOD
IDEA IN THAT CONTEXT.
>> NOT IN ACADEMIA, MICHAEL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: I THINK
I CAN SPEAK FOR MICHAEL.
YOU WOULD SUPPORT MANDATORY
RETIREMENT FOR PROFESSORS.
>> MICHAEL KLARMAN: I WOULD.
>> LINDA GREENHOUSE: I
THINK THE 18 YEAR TERM.
I THINK I READ
THAT STUDENT NOTE.
IT'S WORTH DISCUSSING FOR THE
REASONS THAT MICHAEL SAID.
THE NOTION THAT SUPREME COURT
NOMINEES SHOULD VOLUNTARILY
PLEDGE THAT THEY WOULD DO IT
STRIKES ME AS KIND OF NUTTY.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT DEMOCRACY,
OR WHAT PASSES AS DEMOCRACY
HAS SPREAD AROUND THE WORLD
AND DIFFERENT COUNTRIES
HAVE ADOPTED ASPECTS
OF OUR SYSTEM,
INCLUDING CONSTITUTIONAL COURTS.
NOT A SINGLE COUNTRY
HAS ADOPTED LIFE TENURE.
THEY EITHER HAVE AGE LIMITS,
THEY HAVE TERM LIMITS.
OF THE 50 STATES,
ONLY RHODE ISLAND
HAS LIFE TENURE FOR ITS JUDGES.
EVERY OTHER STATE HAS EITHER
TERM LIMIT OR AGE LIMITS.
SO THESE SYSTEMS ARE
VOTING WITH THEIR FEET THAT
THERE IS SOMETHING A LITTLE
PROBLEMATIC ABOUT IT.
AND IT CERTAINLY DOES ELEVATE
THE KIND OF DRAMA AROUND ANY
SUPREME COURT VACANCY BECAUSE
YOU'RE LOOKING OUT AT SUCH A
LONG TIMELINE.
AND AS MICHAEL SAID, JUSTICES
ARE GETTING APPOINTED AT
YOUNGER AND YOUNGER AGES.
JOHN ROBERTS AT 50 WAS
THE YOUNGEST CHIEF JUSTICE
TO BE APPOINTED
SINCE JOHN MARSHALL.
SO THERE'S STUFF TO
DISCUSS ABOUT THIS.
IT'S A WORTHWHILE CONVERSATION,
BUT IT'S A VERY LONG TERM ONE.
AND EXTRACTING PROMISES FROM
NOMINEES IS NOT THE ANSWER,
I'M PRETTY SURE OF THAT.
>> LAUREN SUDEALL LUCAS: I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT I DON'T KNOW IF
IMPLEMENTING THESE TYPES
OF PROPOSALS WOULD HELP.
BUT I THINK THERE'S A REAL
NEED AND PERHAPS HAVING MORE
FREQUENT TURNOVER
WOULD HELP WITH
THIS, HAVING A DIVERSITY OF
EXPERIENCE NOT JUST TALK ABOUT
DIVERSITY OF RACE AND GENDER
IN TERMS OF WHO'S ON THE COURT.
BUT ALSO DIVERSITY OF EXPERIENCE
AND HAVING A RELATIVELY RECENT
EXPERIENCE WITH HOW
CASES ARE LITIGATED
IN PRACTICE, PARTICULARLY IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
I LIVE IN A STATE WHERE PEOPLE
ARE ROUTINELY UNREPRESENTED BY
COUNSEL.
THE CASES ARE RESOLVED
WITHOUT A DEFENDANT EVEN
SPEAKING TO A LAWYER.
AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
PROSECUTORIAL EXPERIENCE,
OR PUBLIC DEFENDER EXPERIENCE
AND ACTUALLY KNOWING HOW THESE
THINGS WORK ON THE GROUND AND
PRACTICE OBSERVING INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN CITIZENS AND
POLICE WOULD REALLY HELP
WITH HELPING THE COURT GRAPPLE
WITH THESE ISSUES AS THEY TRY
TO DECIDE HOW TO DEAL
WITH IT AT THIS LEVEL,
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THINGS
OPERATE ON THE GROUND.
[APPLAUSE]
>> MARGARET MARSHALL: I
WOULD ADD ONE LAST THING.
I THINK I'M CORRECT,
MAYBE I'M NOT.
BUT I THINK THIS IS THE FIRST
COURT EVER WHERE THERE'S BEEN
NOBODY WITH ANY
STATE EXPERIENCE.
AND I DON'T MEAN
JUST STATE, JUDICIAL.
BUT JUSTICE SOUTER HAD OF
COURSE BEEN A STATE COURT JUDGE,
AND CHIEF JUSTICE
WARREN, GOVERNOR.
PEOPLE HAVE HAD
STATE EXPERIENCE.
I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THAT
WE ARE BECOMING AN INCREASINGLY
FEDERALIZED COURT.
MICHAEL, I DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
YOU OR JOHN WHO TOLD ME THIS
YEAR THE COURT HAS TAKEN A VERY
FEW NUMBER OF CASES FROM STATE
COURTS.
AND THAT'S WHERE MOST OF
THE JUSTICE GETS DONE.
I FOR ONE HAVE A PROPOSAL
THAT IF WE HAVE LIMITED
TENURE, EITHER BY
AGE LIMITATION, OR BY
NUMBERS OF YEARS SERVED, THAT
IT NOT BE IMPLEMENTED UNTIL
AFTER THE LAST SITTING JUDGE
HAS NO LONGER APPLIED TO THEM,
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S VERY
PROBLEMATIC WHEN YOU TRY
TO DO IT WITH A SITTING COURT.
AND IN ANY EVENT, I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK JOHN ADAMS
IN THE MASSACHUSETTS
CONSTITUTION FOR TELLING US
THAT WE HAD LIFETIME TENURE.
BECAUSE IF WE DIDN'T,
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THIS
EXTRAORDINARY,
BRILLIANT, WONDERFUL,
AMAZING WOMAN THAT WE HAVE
TO CELEBRATE HERE TODAY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SO IF YOU ARE A
LAWYER, ESPECIALLY ONE
WHO'S JUST BEGINNING
THEIR CAREER, WHAT
IS THE VERY, VERY, VERY
BEST JOB IN THE WORLD
THAT YOU COULD POSSIBLY HAVE?
IT IS NO DOUBT TO BE A LAW
CLERK FOR JUSTICE RUTH BADER
GINSBURG.
AND MICHAEL KLARMAN IS
GOING TO GIVE US A LITTLE
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT IT IS
LIKE TO HAVE THAT BEAUTIFUL
POSITION.
MICHAEL?
[APPLAUSE]
>> MICHAEL KLARMAN: THANK YOU.
WHEN PRESIDENT CLINTON
NOMINATED RUTH BADER GINSBURG
TO THE SUPREME COURT
IN 1993, HE SAID
QUOTE MANY ADMIRERS
OF HER WORK SAID
THAT SHE IS TO THE WOMEN'S
MOVEMENT WHAT FORMER SUPREME
COURT JUSTICE
THURGOOD MARSHALL WAS
TO MOVEMENT OF THE RIGHTS
OF AFRICAN AMERICANS.
CLINTON WHO WAS A GRADUATE
OF A LAW SCHOOL OTHER
THAN HARVARD THAT SHALL NOT BE
NAMED, EXPLAINED THAT HE COULD
THINK OF NO GREATER
COMPLIMENT TO BESTOW ON
AN AMERICAN LAWYER.
INDEED JUSTICE GINSBURG
IS ONE OF THE FEW JUSTICES
IN AMERICAN HISTORY WHO WOULD
BE A DESERVED FAMOUS AMERICAN IF
SHE HAD NEVER SERVED
ON THE SUPREME COURT.
I AM GOING TO TELL YOU A FEW
STORIES ABOUT JUSTICE GINSBURG
AND HER BIOGRAPHY AND HER
ROLE AS A TRAILBLAZING
LITIGATOR FOR SOCIAL REFORM.
AS MARGIE SAID, I HAD
THE GOOD FORTUNATE TO
CLERK FOR HER 30 YEARS AGO.
SO I KNOW SOME OF THESE STORIES
AS A RESULT OF HAVING WRITTEN
SOME ABOUT HER IN THE PAST.
GINSBURG'S PERSONAL
STORY ILLUSTRATES
WHAT THE PROFESSIONAL WORLD WAS
LIKE FOR WOMEN HALF A CENTURY
AGO.
HOW MUCH IT'S CHANGED SINCE
THEN, AND HOW THE EFFORTS
OF A TALENTED AND HARD
WORKING LAWYER CAN CONTRIBUTE
TO PROGRESSIVE SOCIAL REFORM.
WHEN GINSBURG ENTERED
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL IN 1956,
SHE WAS ONE OF ONLY NINE
WOMEN IN A CLASS OF OVER 500.
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL HAD NOT
ADMITTED WOMAN AT ALL UNTIL
1950.
AT THE TIME THAT GINSBURG WAS
MATRICULATED AT HLS, WOMEN WERE
NOT PERMITTED TO LIVE IN
LAW SCHOOL DORMITORIES,
AND THEY WERE DENIED
ACCESS TO DINING TABLES
AT THE FACULTY CLUB.
AND THE ANNUAL LAW
REVIEW BANQUET ENCOURAGED
MEMBERS TO BRING WITH THEM THEIR
FATHERS, BUT NOT THEIR MOTHERS
OR THEIR WIVES.
EARLY IN THE SCHOOL YEAR THE LAW
SCHOOL'S DEAN INVITED THE NINE
WOMEN IN THE CLASS TO HIS
HOUSE FOR DINNER AND DURING THE
COURSE OF THE
EVENING'S CONVERSATION,
HE ASKED THEM WHY THEY WANTED
TO ATTEND HARVARD LAW SCHOOL,
TAKING UP A SPACE THAT A MAN
COULD PRESUMEDLY PUT TO BETTER
USE.
GINS BURG REPORTS BEING
UNPREPARED FOR THE QUESTION.
NOW AS YOU MAY KNOW HER
SPOUSE, MARTY GINSBURG
WAS A YEAR AHEAD OF HER
AT HARVARD LAW SCHOOL.
AND AS SHE LATER RECOUNTS
HER REJOINDER TO THE DEAN,
ALL I COULD THINK TO
SAY WAS THAT MY HUSBAND
WAS IN THE SECOND YEAR
CLASS, AND IT WAS IMPORTANT
FOR A WIFE TO UNDERSTAND
HER HUSBAND'S WORK.
[LAUGHTER]
FEW PEOPLE AT THAT POINT COULD
HAVE CONFIDENTLY PREDICTED
THERE WOULD EVER BE A WOMAN ON
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
AND INDEED THERE WAS NOT
FOR ANOTHER 25 YEARS.
GINSBURG TRANSFERRED TO COLUMBIA
LAW SCHOOL AFTER TWO YEARS AT
HARVARD WHEN MARTY
GRADUATED AND TOOK
A JOB WITH A NEW YORK LAW FIRM.
THEY WERE RAISING A YOUNG
DAUGHTER AT THE TIME.
GINSBURG GRADUATED IN 1959.
SHE WAS TIED FOR FIRST
IN HER CLASS AT COLUMBIA,
AND SHE HAD BEEN ON THE LAW
REVIEW BOTH AT COLUMBIA AND AT
HARVARD.
YET HER PROFESSORS HAD
TROUBLE FINDING HER A FEDERAL
CLERK COURTSHIP, EVEN THOUGH SHE
WAS EMINENTLY QUALIFIED FOR IT.
NO FEDERAL JUDGE IN
THE NEW YORK CITY AREA
WOULD HIRE A YOUNG
MOTHER AS A LAW CLERK.
FINALLY ONE OF HER
PROFESSORS, GERALD GUNTHER,
PREVAILED UPON A FEDERAL
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE EDMOND
PALMIERI TO HIRE GINSBURG BY
OFFERING A PERSONAL GUARANTEE
THAT IF SHE DID NOT WORK OUT HE
WOULD FIND A MALE REPLACEMENT.
SHE WORKED OUT SO WELL THAT IN
THE FUTURE PALMIERI COULD NOT
GET ENOUGH FEMALE CLERKS.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW
JUSTICE GINSBURG
WAS THE LEADING WOMENS RIGHTS
LAWYER IN THE UNITED STATES
IN THE 1970S.
SHE ARGUED 6 LANDMARK CASES
IN THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT, WINNING 5 OF THEM.
NOW ONE FAIRLY UNIQUE
OBSTACLE CONFRONTED BY LAWYERS
FOR SOCIAL REFORM IS EVEN
HAVING THEIR ARGUMENTS TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
IN 1938 CHARLES
HAMILTON HOUSTON,
ONE OF THE LEADING
BLACK CIVIL RIGHTS
LITIGATORS IN THE COUNTRY AND A
GRADUATE OF HARVARD LAW SCHOOL
LITERALLY HAD ONE OF THE
JUSTICES TURN HIS BACK
ON HIM IN DURING ORAL
ARGUMENT IN A LANDMARK RACE
DISCRIMINATION CASE
IN ORDER TO INDICATE
HIS PROFOUND DISRESPECT
FOR A BLACK MAN.
40 YEARS LATER, ORAL ADVOCATE
RUTH BADER GINSBURG HAD TO
CONFRONT CONDESCENDING
HUMOR FROM THE BENCH AS SHE
CHALLENGED THE EXCLUSION
OF WOMEN FROM JURIES
IN THE STATE OF MISSOURI.
AFTER GINSBURG HAS
CONCLUDED HER ORAL ARGUMENT
IN THE CASE, ONE OF THE JUSTICES
LEANED OVER FROM THE BENCH TO
ASK ONE FINAL QUESTION.
YOU WON'T SETTLE
FOR PUTTING SUSAN B.
ANTHONY ON THE DOLLAR
THEN I TAKE IT?
IN ANOTHER LANDMARK CASE ONE
OF THE JUSTICES PRIVATELY
CRITISIZED GINSBURG'S
BRIEF AS BEING EMOTIONAL,
INVOKING ONE OF THE TRADITIONAL
GENDER PUTDOWNS OF THE ERA.
IN ADDITION TO THE CHALLENGE
OF BEING TAKEN SERIOUSLY,
ONE OF THE PRINCIPLE
DIFFICULTIES THAT SOCIAL REFORM
LITIGATORS FACE IS
CONVINCING JUSTICES
OF THE UNFAIRNESS OF A SYSTEM,
UNDER WHICH THEY THEMSELVES HAD
BENEFITED AND WHICH
HAD BECOME GROUNDED
IN AN IDEOLOGY SO PERVASIVE THAT
THEY HAD TROUBLE EVEN NOTICING
THAT IT'S ASSUMPTIONS
ARE CONTROVERSIAL.
GINSBURG CONFRONTED
EXACTLY THAT PROBLEM TRYING
TO CONVINCE ELDERLY MALE
JUSTICES IN THE 1970S
OF THE INSIDIOUS CONSEQUENCES
OF SEX CLASSIFICATIONS.
VIRTUALLY ALL SEX
CLASSIFICATIONS ARE AS JUSTICE
GINSBURG LIKES TO SAY
A DOUBLE EDGED SWORD.
MANY SUCH STATUTES TANGIBLY
DISADVANTAGE MALES AND NOT
FEMALES, THAT THEY INTANGIBLY
HARM WOMEN BY PERPETUATING
STEREOTYPES OF FEMALE
DEPENDENCY, PASSIVITY,
AND LACK OF BUSINESS ABILITY.
GINSBURG NEEDED TO CONVINCE
THESE JUSTICES THAT WOMEN WERE
HARMED FOR EXAMPLE BY STATUTES
THAT REQUIRED MEN BUT NOT
WOMEN TO PAY ALIMONY OR THAT
PERMITTED WOMEN, BUT NOT MEN
THE CHOICE OF WHETHER
TO SERVE ON A JURY.
IN A TELLING CONVERSATION WITH
HARVARD LAW SCHOOL STUDENTS
EARLY IN 1973, ONE OF THE MALE
JUSTICES AND THERE WERE ONLY
MALE JUSTICES IN 1973
EXPRESSED BEWILDERMENT AS TO
WHY WOMEN WANTED AN
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT.
IN HIS VIEW, THE
FEMALE OF THE SPECIES
HAS THE BEST OF BOTH WORLDS.
SHE CAN ATTACK LAWS THAT
UNREASONABLY DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST HER, WHILE PRESERVING
THOSE THAT FAVOR HER.
GINSBURG REPORTED
BEING DEPRESSED
WHEN SHE HEARD THE
ACCOUNT OF THAT SPEECH.
A LENGTHY EXCHANGE
BETWEEN GINSBURG AND TWO
OF THE JUSTICES
AT ORAL ARGUMENT,
IN THE CASE OF CALIFANO V.
GOLDFARB IN 1976 REVEALS HOW
DIFFICULT IT WAS TO CONVINCE
ELDERLY MALE JUSTICES THAT ALL
SEX CLASSIFICATIONS ADVERSELY
AFFECTED WOMEN BECAUSE
OF THIS DOUBLE EDGED NATURE.
THE SOCIAL SECURITY
PROVISION THAT
WAS AT ISSUE IN GOLDFARB
AUTOMATICALLY PROVIDED
SURVIVORS BENEFITS FOR
THE WIDOWS OF COVERED MALE
EMPLOYEES, BUT REQUIRED
THAT THE WIDOWERS
OF COVERED FEMALE EMPLOYEES
DEMONSTRATE ACTUAL
ECONOMIC DEPENDENCY
ON THEIR SPOUSES.
TO GINSBURG SUCH A PROVISION
HAD THREE DIFFERENT FLAWS.
FIRST OF ALL IT DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST FEMALE WAGE EARNERS,
SECOND IT DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST THE MALE BENEFICIARIES,
AND THIRD IT PROPETUATED THE
PERFIDIOUS SEX STEREOTYPE THAT
MALES WERE PRIMARILY BREAD
WINNERS AND WOMEN WERE
PREDOMINANTLY HOMEMAKERS.
SOME OF THE JUSTICES HAD
DIFFICULTY SEEING THESE POINTS.
THE FIRST QUESTION
THAT WAS DIRECTED
TO GINSBURG FROM THE BENCH WAS
WHETHER THE PROVISION AT ISSUE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
MALES OR FEMALES,
WHETHER IT COULD NOT BE CAST
IN EITHER WAY, AND WHY SHE HAD
CHOSEN TO TREAT IT AS AN
ANTI FEMALE DISCRIMINATION.
IF THE SEXES WERE SWITCHED,
AND ONLY FEMALE BENEFICIARIES,
WHERE WE'RE REQUIRED TO
ESTABLISH ACTUAL FINANCIAL
DEPENDENCY, ONE JUSTICE
WONDERED WOULD THAT MAKE A
CONSTITUTIONAL DIFFERENCE?
GINSBURG'S RESPONSE
WAS THE LINE DRAWN HERE
LIKE VIRTUALLY EVERY GENDER
DISCRIMINATION IS A TWO EDGE
SWORD.
HER INTERLOCUTOR PERSISTED.
SOME RECENT COURT
DECISIONS HAD FOCUSED ON
THE HISTORY OF
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST WOMEN,
BUT HE DOUBTED THAT
ANY ANALOGOUS HISTORY
OF DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST MEN EXISTED.
GINS BURG RESPONDED THAT MOST
ANTI-FEMALE DISCRIMINATION
WAS DRESSED UP AS DISCRIMINATION
FAVORING THE WOMEN.
THE JUSTICE REPLIED
IMPATIENTLY, I KNOW THAT.
I KNOW THAT BUT
THE COURTS THROUGH
HELP OF ADVOCATES SUCH AS
YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO SEE
THAT, HAVENT THEY?
THAT COMMENT ELICITED
LAUGHTER IN THE COURTROOM.
GINS BURG GAMELY
REITERATED THAT SEX
CLASSIFICATIONS ALMOST
INEVITABLEY HARMED WOMEN.
PERSISTING THIS
JUSTICE ASKED HER
TO IMAGINE AN INSTANCE OF
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST MALES.
WOULD HER CONSTITUTIONAL
ARGUMENT BE EQUALLY STRONG?
GINSBURG REPLIED THAT HER
ARGUMENT WOULD REMAIN UNCHANGED
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
OF ANY PURELY ANTI-MALE
DISCRIMINATION.
IN THE END, THE WOMEN ARE
THE ONES WHO END UP HURTING.
IN A MOMENT LATER,
ANOTHER OF THE JUSTICES
TOOK UP THE SAME
LINE OF QUESTIONING.
SHOULD DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST MALES
BE SUBJECTED TO THE SAME
STANDARD AS DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST FEMALES OR
TO A DIFFERENT ONE?
GINSBURG REPEATED
HER PREVIOUS ANSWER.
ALMOST EVERY DISCRIMINATION
THAT OPERATES AGAINST
MALES OPERATES AGAINST
FEMALES, AS WELL.
BEWILDERED AND APPARENTLY
ANNOYED, THE JUSTICE RESPONDED
IS THAT A YES OR A NO ANSWER?
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND YOU.
ARE YOU TRYING TO
AVOID THE QUESTION?
GINSBURG INSISTED SHE WAS
TRYING TO CLARIFY, NOT EVADE.
SHE WAS AWARE OF NO SEX
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT DID
NOT OPERATE AS A
DOUBLE EDGED SWORD.
THE EXCHANGE WENT
ON TO SIMLAR EFFECT
FOR A WHILE LONGER THEN CAME
THE FOLLOWING QUESTION FROM THE
BENCH.
BUT YOUR ANSWER ALWAYS
DEPENDS ON THERE FINDING SOME
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST FEMALES.
YOU SEEM TO PUT THAT IN EVERY
ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION.
YES.
GINSBURG WHO MUST
HAVE BEEN GROWING
EXASPERATED AT THIS POINT
REITERATED THAT QUOTE.
I HAVE NOT YET COME ACROSS A
STATUTE THAT DOESN'T HAVE THAT
AFFECT.
HER QUESTIONER PERSISTED.
I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP.
BUT IF THERE WERE ONE, THEN
WOULD YOU SAY IT WOULD BE
TREATED UNDER A DIFFERENT
STANDARD I TAKE IT?
NOT WISHING TO ALIENATE
A POTENTIAL ALLY,
OR TO MAKE A CONCESION
THAT COULD HARM HER
CASE, GINSBURG RELENTED.
IF THERE WERE SUCH A
STATUTE, SHE WOULD RESERVE
JUDGMENT ON WHAT THE
STANDARD WOULD BE.
BUT SHE REPEATED SHE HAD YET
TO COME ACROSS SUCH A STATUTE.
THE JUSTICES WHO
WERE ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS WERE VERY SMART MEN.
THEIR INABILITY
TO COMPREHEND WHAT
WOULD STRIKE MOST OF US TODAY
AS A FAIRLY SELF EVIDENT POINT
SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT SOCIAL REFORM
LAWYERS FACE IN CONFRONTING
THE DEEPLY ROOTED IDEOLOGIES
THAT MAKE A SYSTEM OF OPPRESSION
SEEM JUST AND NATURAL.
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT GINSBURG
FACED IN COURT OF CONVINCING
MALE JUSTICES AS WHY SEX
CLASSIFICATIONS WERE HARMFUL TO
WOMEN AND AS SHE WOULD WANT ME
TO ADD TO MEN AS WELL.
BUT NOW I WANT TO TURN TO
ANOTHER ASPECT OF THE JOB
OF SOCIAL REFORM LITIGATORS.
WE TEND TO THINK OF
LAWYERS AS PEOPLE
WHO GO INTO COURT IN
PURSUANCE OF A LEGAL CLAIM.
BUT IN SOME WAYS THE
MOST IMPORTANT JOB
OF THE SOCIAL REFORM
LITIGATOR DOES NOT TAKE
PLACE IN THE COURTROOM AT ALL.
THE STRATEGY OF THE
WOMEN'S RIGHTS PROJECT,
WHICH GINSBURG HEAD IN THE 1970S
INCLUDED NOT JUST LITIGATING
CASES, BUT ALSO LOBBYING
LEGISLATURES, TRAINING LAWYERS,
AND EDUCATING THE
GENERAL PUBLIC ABOUT
ISSUES OF SEX DISCRIMINATION.
GINSBURG AND THE WRP OFFERED
ASSISTANCE TO ACLU AFFILIATES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
WHO WERE ENGAGING
IN SEX DISCRIMINATION
LITIGATTION.
SHE ADVISED THEM ON
PRIORITIES AND THE WRP SERVED
AS A CLEARINGHOUSE
FOR INFORMATION,
BOTH ABOUT PENDING SEX
DISCRIMINATION CASES AND ABOUT
LAWYERS WHO WERE WILLING
TO HELP OUT WITH THEM.
AFTER HER LEGAL VICTORIES,
GINSBURG WOULD WRITE MEMOS
TO ACLU AFFILIATES
INSTRUCTING THEM ON HOW
TO PURSUE FOLLOW UP LITIGATION
AND LEGISLATIVE LOBBYING.
GINSBURG DEVOTED
AT LEAST AS MUCH
OF HER TIME TO EDUCATING PEOPLE
ABOUT SEX DISCRIMINATION AS SHE
DID LITIGATING SEX
EQUALITY CASES.
WHEN HER FEMALE
STUDENTS AT RUTGERS
LAW SCHOOL IN THE 1960S
ASKED FOR A SEMINAR ON WOMEN
AND THE LAW, GINSBURG SPENT A
MONTH IN THE LIBRARY READING
EVERY COURT DECISION
AND LAW REVIEW ARTICLE
ON THE SUBJECT SHE
COULD FIND, WHICH
SHE REPORTS WAS NOT A
VERY TAXING ENDEAVOR,
GIVEN HOW LITTLE THERE WAS.
THEN SHE INITIATED
SUCH A COURSE AND WITH
TWO OF HER COLLEAGUES SHE PUT
TOGETHER ONE OF THE NATION'S
FIRST CASE BOOKS ON
WOMEN AND THE LAW.
SHE ALSO WROTE NUMEROUS
LAW REVIEW ARTICLES
ON SEX DISCRIMINATION
LITIGATION,
AND SHE MAINTAINED A STEADY
STREAM OF CORRESPONDENCE,
WHICH STUDENT LAW REVIEW
EDITORS, URGING THEM TO WRITE
ABOUT RACE AND SEX
DISCRIMINATION CASES, EDUCATING
THEM ABOUT THE ISSUES, AND
PROVIDING THEM WITH BRIEFS
AND OTHER MATERIALS TO
ENHANCE THEIR SCHOLARSHIP.
AND SHE TRAVELED AROUND THE
COUNTRY TESTIFYING BEFORE
LEGISLATURES IN SUPPORT OF
THE EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT
AND SPEAKING TO ACLU AFFILIATES
AND UNIVERSITY AUDIENCES ABOUT
ISSUES OF SEX EQUALITY.
SHE WAS AN ORGANIZER, A
MOBILIZER, A PUBLICIST
AND AN EDUCATOR FOR THE
SEX EQUALITY MOVEMENT,
MUCH AS THURGOOD MARSHALL
HAD BEEN FOR THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT A GENERATION EARLIER.
WHLE DOING ALL THESE THINGS THE
SOCIAL REFORM LITIGATOR ALSO
HAS TO FACE THE DAY TO DAY
CHALLENGES POSED BY AN UNJUST
STATUS QUO THAT THEY'RE
LITIGATING AGAINST.
WHEN ARGUING RACE
DISCRIMINATION CASES
IN THE SUPREME COURT
IN THE 1930S AND 1940S,
THURGOOD MARSHALL HAD A HARD
TIME FINDING A RESTAURANT TO
EAT AT IN THE
THOROUGHLY SEGREGATED
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA.
GINS BURG FACED A SIMILAR
CHALLENGE AS CAPTURED
IN A STORY SHE TELLS
FROM THIS TIME PERIOD.
NOW REMEMBER, SHE'S A TENURED
PROFESSOR AT COLUMBIA LAW
SCHOOL, SHE'S HEAD
OF THE WOMEN'S RIGHTS
PROJECT, SHE'S A
SUPREME COURT LITIGATOR
AND A FREQUENT WITNESS ACRSS THE
COUNTRY ON BEHALF OF THE ERA.
BUT SHE'S ALSO RECEIVING
REPEATED PHONE CALLS AT HER
OFFICE ABOUT HER SON JAMES
WHO IS THEN TEN YEARS
OLD WHO IS ACTING UP AT SCHOOL
IN THE WAY 10 YEAR OLDS ARE
WANT TO DO.
FINALY EXASPERATED AT THE
REPEATED PHONE CALLS GINSBURG
RESPONDED TO ONE
OF THEM AS FOLLOWS.
THIS CHILD HAS TWO PARENTS.
I SUGGEST FROM NOW ON
YOU ALTERNATE BETWEEN
THEM WHEN YOU NEED TO SPEAK
TO SOMEONE ABOUT JAMES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
GINSBURG REPORTS THAT EVEN
THOUGH JAMES' BEHAVIOR DID NOT
MATERIALLY IMPROVE,
THE PHONE CALL CEASED
BECAUSE THE SCHOOL
WOULD NOT DREAM
OF BOTHERING A BUSY MALE TAX
ATTORNEY AT HIS OFFICE DURING
WORKING HOURS.
SOCIAL REFORM LAWYERS NOT
ONLY MOBILIZED PROTESTS,
THEY ALSO PROVIDE,
I'M ALMOST DONE,
VALUABLE ROLE MODELS FOR MEMBERS
OF TRADITIONALLY SUBORDINATED
GROUPS.
IN 1960 OF COURSE, THERE
HAD NEVER BEEN A WOMAN
ON THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT.
THERE HAD BEEN ONLY TWO
OR THREE FEDERAL FEMALE
JUDGES IN THE HISTORY
OF THE COUNTRY.
IN THE LATE 1940S, PRESIDENT
HARRY TRUMAN APPARENTLY BRIEFLY
CONSIDERED APPOINTING A WOMAN
TO THE SUPREME COURT, FLORENCE
ALAN, WHO WAS SITTING ON THE 6TH
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS, BUT
WHEN HE CONSULTED WITH
THE SITTING JUSTICES,
APPARENTLY THAT WAS A MISTAKE,
THEY URGED AGAINST DOING SO,
APPARENTLY THEIR CONCERN WAS
THAT HER PRESENCE WOULD INHIBIT
THEM FROM TAKING OFF THEIR TIES
AND KICKING UP THEIR FEET AT
CONFERENCE.
IN THE MID 1960S,
WOMEN WERE ONLY
ABOUT 1% OF SUPREME
COURT LITIGATORS.
LESS THAN 2% OF THE
NATION'S LAW PROFESSORS.
JUSTICE GINSBURG DID NOT HAVE A
SINGLE FEMALE PROFESSOR DURING
HER THREE YEARS OF LAW SCHOOL.
NOT UNTIL 1970, IF
YOU CAN BELIEVE THIS,
DID THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
OF LAW SCHOOLS AMMEND ITS RULES
TO BAR SEX DISCRIMINATION
AT MEMBER INSTITUTIONS
AND AS OF THAT YEAR
WOMEN WERE ONLY
ABOUT 10% OF LAW
SCHOOL STUDENT BODIES.
GINSBURG APPRECIATED
THE IMPORTANCE
OF FEMALE LAWYERS PARTICIPATING
IN SEX EQUALITY CASES.
WHEN SHE LEARNED OF THE ACLU'S
INVOLVEMENT AND WHAT TURNED OUT
TO BE THE SUPREME COURT'S
LANDMARK SEX EQUALITY
DECISION IN 1971.
SHE ASKED THE ORGANIZATION'S
LEGAL DIRECTOR WHETHER
A WOMAN OUGHT NOT TO BE INVOLVED
AS CO-COUNCIL IN THE CASE.
HE AGREED AND OFFERED
HER TO JOIN HIM.
IN WRP LITIGATION WOMEN'S RIGHTS
PROJECTS LITIGATION GINSBURG
LATER NOTED,
PARTICULAR ATTENTION
WAS GIVEN TO ENCOURAGING
PARTICIPATION BY WOMEN LAWYERS
WHO SEEK ASSISTANCE IN
MAINTAINING THEIR SKILLS DURING
PERIODS WHEN FAMILY
RESPONSIBILITIES PREVENT
THEM FROM WORKING FULL TIME.
GINSBURG'S LEADERSHIP
OF THE WRP AND HER ORAL
ADVOCACY IN THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT WERE
INSPIRATIONAL TO
COUNTLESS WOMEN.
SHE HERSELF NEVER FAILED
TO HIGHLIGHT THE COUNTLESS
CONTRIBUTIONS OF PAST
GENERATIONS OF FEMINISTS TO HER
OWN WORK.
IN HER BRIEF IN THE COURT'S
LANDMARK SEX DISCRIMINATION
CASE, SHE PLACED THE NAMES OF
TRAILBLAZING FEMINISTS DOROTHY
KENYON AND PAULI MURRAY
ON THE TITLE PAGE
AS A SYMBOLIC ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF
THE INTELLECTUAL DEBT OWED TO
THEM BY CONTEMPORARY FEMINISTS.
AND LATER AS A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE SHE WROTE NUMEROUS
ARTICLES DESCRIBING
THE CONTRIBUTION
OF PIONEERING FEMINIST
LAWYERS AND JUDGES, AS WELL
AS THE WIVES OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
MANY SOCIAL REFORM
ACTIVISTS DO NOT LIVE TO
SEE THE DAY THAT THEIR
DREAMS ARE REALIZED.
MANY OF THE FIRST GENERATION OF
ABOLITIONISTS DID NOT SURVIVE
TO SEE THE ENACTMENT OF THE 13TH
AMENDMENT ENDING OF SLAVERY.
AND SUSAN B. ANTHONY AND
ELIZABETH CADY STANTON DID NOT
LIVE TO SEE THE ENACTMENT OF
THE 19TH AMENDMENT ENFRANCHISING
WOMEN.
JUSTICE GINSBURG, OF
COURSE, HAS NOT ONLY LIVED
TO SEE THE ENORMOUS
CHANGES IN SEX EQUALITY,
BUT HAS HELPED TO BRING THEM
ABOUT AS A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE AS IN HER LANDMARK
DECISION 20 YEARS AGO REQUIRING
VIRGINIA MILITARY
INSTITUTE TO ADMIT WOMEN.
JUSTICE GINSBURG, WE'RE SO
HAPPY YOU'VE AFFORDED US THIS
OCCASION TODAY.
IN CELEBRATING YOUR
EXTRAORDINARY CONTRIBUTIONS
BOTH TO SEX EQUALITY AND
MORE GENERALLY MAKING
OURS A MORE JUST SOCIETY.
WE'RE ALL IN YOUR DEBT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH MICHAEL.
AND DID I TELL YOU THAT
WAS THE VERY BEST JOB
TO HAVE IN THE WORLD.
LIZ, ARE YOU GOING TO
THANK OUR PANELISTS?
>> TWO THINGS I'M GOING TO SAY.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO THANK THEM?
>> I AM.
AND YOU!
I WILL JUST TIE THINGS
UP HERE QUICKLY.
I WANT TO THANK MARGIE
AND THE PANELISTS.
YOU'VE TAUGHT US A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT THE FIRST DECADE OF THE
ROBERTS COURT.
AND I THINK YOU
HAVE EQUIPPED US,
YOU HAVE EQUIPPED US WELL FOR
A FUTURE OF COURT WATCHING.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUDIENCE
FOR JOINING US THIS MORNING.
IN CAMBRIDGE AND
THE MANY PEOPLE WHO
ARE ONLINE TO HONOR JUSTICE
RUTH BADER GINSBURG.
[MUSIC]